foreign
hey everyone welcome to this video on
SEO full course today we'll begin this
full course video with what is SEO and
how SEO works then we will be looking at
a bunch of on-page and off-page elements
after this we will learn how to analyze
and measure website metrics using Google
Analytics tool we will also see how to
use Google tag manager then we will
discuss some of the important techniques
to rank number one on Google and YouTube
simple ways to increase website traffic
basic knowledge of SEO tools and finally
we will conclude this video by
discussing the important tips and tricks
of SEO for this training with me I have
our experienced AWS specialist Rob and
Rahul together we will take you through
the various topics of SEO
so let's start with an exciting video on
SEO full course before we begin make
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn
Rachel is a baker who runs her own
Bakery to expand her business she
decided to create an online presence by
first setting up a Blog she began
posting on her blog regularly however
even after regularly posting on the blog
there were barely any visitors showing
up deciding not to give up Rachel began
searching for a solution on the internet
that's when she came across SEO or
search engine optimization a term she's
never heard before so let's take a
journey together and help her learn
about SEO search engine optimization is
a method that could improve the quality
and quantity of the audience coming to
Rachel's website from search engines it
could increase brand awareness attract
local customers and build credibility
and trust and all of this is possible
without having to spend a single penny
to bring visitors to our website Rachel
would have to take advantage of the two
types of SEO on-page and off-page SEO
Rachel first decides to tackle on-page
SEO and get that sorted on-page SEO
involved Rachel optimizing her website
both in terms of content and the
technical aspects including the HTML
source code schema meta Tags and More
she started off by using tools like
Google AdWords allref and semrush to
identify popular Search terms associated
with the recipes she planned to publish
on her blog she began to look for Search
terms related to the broader area of
baking cooking and related topics once
she found these Search terms she began
to incorporate them into her recipes
she started off by providing an
introduction to the recipe with this she
could provide an engaging beginning to
her story like how the dish reminded her
of her childhood and enabled her to
naturally include the Search terms into
the blog she also included these
keywords in the actual recipe as well
additionally she added pictures videos
time lapses and more to increase
credibility and engagement for her
content and subsequently persuading
search engines to show her content to
more people after this she moved to the
website metacontent that search engines
display when her blog appears in search
results she optimized The Meta tax alt
tags header Tags and More this completed
the on-page aspect of SEO thanks to this
she saw a significant increase in the
number of visitors coming to her page
having done all she could on her webpage
she now decides to explore what could be
done off page to improve her Page's
visibility on search engines off-page
SEO involved Rachel doing things out
inside her site page to help increase
its search engine rankings making
optimizations outside the site would
improve the site's popularity relevance
trustworthiness and Authority this is
possible with the help of reputable
websites vouching for your content with
backlinks social media marketing guest
blogging linked unlinked brand mentions
influencer marketing and much more
Rachel also understood that for her
content to reach people she would have
to promote it on social media platforms
like Facebook Twitter and Instagram as
well as Niche platforms like quora
Reddit and medium
these could help her achieve greater
reach for her website by sending
stronger social signals to search
engines leading to the page being shown
as highly relevant for related searches
and audiences and even after
understanding and implementing all of
this Rachel had just scratched the
surface of what was possible with SEO
before we find out what she did next
let's have a look at a quiz
which of the following is the most
effective way to improve off-page SEO
one creating plenty of web pages of a
Content 2. getting backlinks from
relevant and authoritative sites 3.
acquiring backlinks through link Buy
4. none of the above let us know your
answer in the comments section below for
a chance to win an Amazon voucher now
let's go back to Rachel Rachel decided
to take up simplylearn's digital
marketing certification with classes
covering just about everything she
needed to know about SEO it was only a
matter of time before Rachel began to
implement her learnings on her website
and see a massive uptick in the number
of viewers coming to her website in time
she could even earn money off the site
by setting up an online shop and with
that we've covered an introduction to
the concepts of SEO welcome my name is
Rob Sanders I'm a course instructor at
simply learn today we're going to talk
about why you would want to rank using
SEO and SEO as search engine
optimization also known as organic
search you also May us here a say
organic listings where we're going to
talk a little bit about why you would
want to rank your website in organic
search okay what is search engine
Optimum organization then we're going to
follow that up with how does Google rank
websites so why does it rank one website
over another and how do we get our
website to rank number one then we're
going to talk about the different types
of SEO or search engine optimization
techniques so you can get your website
ranked number one and then we're going
to finish that off with the do's and
don'ts of SEO so let's get right to it
and talk about why SEO so we're going to
use a basic example and let's just say
you have a Blog you're a food blogger
you're passionate about food and your
Niche is ice cream and let's just say
you have a lot of ice cream recipes you
want to get traffic to your blog you
want people to read your blog and you're
curious why am I not ranking for my blog
why when people type in ice cream
recipes and say Google my blog posts
don't appear at the top of organic
rankings and there's a number of reasons
why you wouldn't be ranked for or your
blog post or your ice cream recipes and
the main reason would be your
competitors so there could be somebody
else out there who is also passionate
about ice cream and has been blogging a
longer longer than you and they have
more content and more blog posts and
more pages for Google to rank so that's
usually the number one reason the other
reason is improper usage of keywords and
we're going to talk a little bit or it's
actually a lot more about you know
keyword usage in your content so what
kind of keywords do you want to rank for
that's really what we're talking about
when we talk about usage of keywords
what keywords do you want to rank for
and how do we work those keywords into
the content another reason is poor link
building practices and really that means
our other blog posts or other websites
linking to you also are you linking to
other pages on your website and so it's
all about link building and with link
building it's internal linking so are we
linking in from one blog post to another
and it's external linking are other
websites of high quality linking to us
and so that's what we talk about when we
talk about link building and then
another reason is web page load time so
you could be running your blog post on
say WordPress for example and your blog
post isn't loading fast enough well if
you look at it this way think about it
if you're Google would you really want
to rank a website or blog post in this
example number one on Google rankings if
that particular page loaded very slow no
you wouldn't because when somebody
clicked on that link in organic search
and went to your website they're going
to have a bad experience because the
page is going to load slow so Google
doesn't want their users to have a bad
experience you don't want your users to
have a bad experience and so that's why
web page load time is a critical factor
for ranking so we need to make sure that
our web pages load fast and then your
user experience is not good enough so
Google again based on my example about
the web page load time Google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know Google doesn't want any spam
content Google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the web page they
want people to are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what Google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is the indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is Google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a Blog with a hundred recipes you want
Google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on Google organic search so
let's move on to what is SEO so sticking
with our ice cream Blog theme really SEO
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
Google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result is we want all our pages
to be ranked number one for particular
keywords so if you want to be ranked for
ice cream recipes well there's certain
things you need to do so that's
generally how it works we need to apply
search engine optimization to increase a
page for keyword we want to be found for
so let me give you an example so let's
just say there's a hundred students that
participated in an essay competition and
so the competition in this particular
case is evaluated on the basis of is the
content relevant are they using suitable
titles for for their essay do they have
structure when they're participating in
this essay or talking about the essay
and do they have a suitable synopsis and
is the content neat and readable these
seem all logical for an essay
competition well guess what they seem
logical for SEO because that's exactly
how SEO works it's exactly all those
points I just made mentioned about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in SEO and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our Pages
Google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called The Meta
description and then again the the
content needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speed's
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when I say responsive
design that means your site your page
needs to load both on desktop and also
on mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
Google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
Etc on Google Search and then link
building remember I mentioned link
building a moment ago we'll link
building internally and externally also
plays a vital role and so we're going to
talk about that a little bit later in
the class when we talk about off-page
SEO how does Google rank website and
basically Google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your your web pages they need to you
know have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then Google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to basically
write rank though those pages that
they've indexed from number one to
Infinity depending on how many pages are
relevant to that search query so really
it's about crawling indexing and ranking
so crawling is simply a process done by
which Google has Bots and what these
Bots do is they go to your web server
and they're going to crawl every page
that they can find and how do they find
these Pages well they basically follow
links you might have heard the term
Spider-Man that's what they call search
engine spider range so basically what
Google's doing is they're building a web
so to speak all the links that they're
following and so when they can follow
all these links on your website they're
going to be able to crawl them and when
they crawl them basically they're going
to take that content and store it on
their servers so it's available in their
index So based on this method Google
finds out which websites have relevant
content and which ones don't based on
certain keywords that are typed in a
Google Google because if they can't
crawl your website you're not going to
be found and if you can't be found then
you're not going to show up for Relevant
keywords so we need to make sure your
site's available to be crawled and we'll
talk about that a little bit later okay
but let's show you an example so let's
just go to Google Search and if I type
in the keyword simply learn okay I could
see I have 1 million 10 000 results okay
and that's how many results are showing
up for simply learn okay now they may
not all be simply learned pages but
nonetheless simply learned is ranked
number one here organically and there
are one million 10 000 Pages related to
the keyword simply learned now when it
comes to organic search we don't want to
get it confused with paid search so
anytime you see paid search you're going
to see something that says add next to
it okay so we could see that there are
paid ads here but when it comes to
organic search those are generally below
paid ads and so that's where Google
counts the 1 one million 10 000 results
and so that's a whole idea behind
crawling and indexing Google's able to
cross simply learns website and based on
all the pages that they gather they're
going to make those pages available in
organic search so if you type in a
keyword and your web page is not
available for indexing then you're never
going to show up for that keyword so
that's why it's important to make sure
your website is available for crawling
and indexing and so when a user types a
query on search Google search the most
relevant websites that are in Google's
index are going to pair in the search
results so in the example I gave was
simply learn well simply learn is the
brand name of the company simply learned
so there's a lot of relevancy there so
that's why you see simply learn show up
here organically number one like we
mentioned about what is SEO and why SEO
we talked about that user experience so
there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learned example simply
learn is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned Pages because that's who they
are simply learn however simply learn
also needs to make sure that you know
for their Pages the page load time is
fast meaning these Pages load very fast
for the end user and Google also takes
into account other factors like how long
someone is staying on a website or are
they bouncing meaning are they going to
one page that they land on and then
leaving the website okay and so the user
experience is very very important there
are other factors also like language and
location and so for example location if
you do a search say in India the results
are going to be a little bit different
than say the results in the United
States why because Google is indexing as
many web pages as they can find so if
somebody's doing a search in India their
results may be a little bit different
than the results show up in the U.S
because Google has different Bots and
these Bots are crawling different pages
at different times and so Google's index
is updating continuously but it's not
real time syncing so if you do a search
in India you may not see exactly the
same thing because both search engines
the Google and India and the Google and
the US are may not be exactly synced up
so an example would be you know if
you're looking for Cafe so if you search
a cafe and say San Francisco you're
going to see different results now if
you do a search for cafes in Mumbai
you're going to see different results
there's going to be local search here at
the top there may be some paid search
but again you may see different results
because one location but two Google
search engines in India and United
States google.com aren't exactly synced
up exactly at the same exact time you do
that search so locate nation is
important language is important and
relevancy is important along with user
experience so all those are important
factors in how Google ranks websites
okay so we're going to talk about the
types of SEO now so if we want to rank
for a particular keyword on Google we're
going to have to apply search engine
optimization and so there's two
strategies to search engine optimization
on-page SEO and off-page SEO so first
we're going to talk about on-page SEO so
on page SEO is nothing more than
optimizing your own website and so when
we say optimizing your own website
there's certain elements on your website
and on your web pages that we need to
take into account and so some of those
elements are headers meta descriptions
title tags linking so all of those
elements are something we can control as
an end user who wants to rank our
webpage page on our website on Google
and before we do anything with our
website the first thing we need to do is
understand what keywords we want to rank
for in order to understand what keywords
we want to rank for we need to do
keyword research and if you do anything
in SEO keyword research is the most
important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for SEO and
why do I say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on Google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on Google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than a a keyword that has a lot
of competition so we need to understand
those two basic factors volume and
competition before we choose a keyword
and it's it's simply the practice of
going through the motions of getting
your volume and getting your competition
data so you can choose the keywords you
want and then once you choose the
keywords you want then you can go and
apply on page SEO you can change the
title tag The Meta descriptions the
headers all those elements can be
changed but first you need to choose
your keywords and so again the primary
components we're looking for are how
much traffic you can get or the search
volume how much competition there is for
that keyword and of course relevancy
okay you need to be able to choose a
keyword that's relevant to the web page
you're trying to rank for and so let me
show you example how to go through this
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to use a tool and the tool I would
recommend is Google Keyword Planner and
one why do I choose Google Keyword
Planner because if we're trying to rank
on google.com or Google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so Google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if I want to use Google's
Keyword Planner and I want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then I'm going to
type that keyword into Google's Keyword
Planner and what Google's going to do is
they're going to give me some Trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword I can
see that there are trends that that
appear for both desktop and mobile so
mobile is important because people start
their search process a lot of times on
their mobile device so we want to be
able to get data from mobile as well as
desktop and so we could see a trend here
that for each particular month over the
last 12 months we can see how much
volume this particular keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
gets per month and so on average on
average over the past 12 months I could
see how to become a digital marketing
specialist is averages 30 searches a
month and this is on google.com and so
Google gives us the volume what they
also give us is the competition and so
here I can see Google says for that
particular keyword the competition is
medium and so in the Google's Keyword
Planner what they also do is give me
other relevant keywords that I might
think about optimizing for because you
don't want to optimize for just one
keyword so how to become a digital
marketing specialist they're going to
also offer up other types of keywords
that are relevant so just digital
marketing Specialists social media
marketing specialist so for those
keywords I can see see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist I
can see the average volume is one
thousand per month on average of the
last 12 months I can also see the
competition is medium but for some other
keywords I can see the search volume
being high like digital marketing course
at 2900 per month but also the
competition is high and so what I would
recommend is a best practice is to
collect all your relevant keywords okay
and put all your relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet and when you put all these
relevant keywords in a spreadsheet you
want to get the data on those keywords
and the data I'm referring to is the
volume of competition so in this case we
have volume from Google planner Google's
Keyword Planner and I have competition
from Google's Keyword Planner and so if
I go into a spreadsheet and I put all
that information in here I'm going to be
able to see the volume and competition
and so that's important however one
thing to note here is that Google's
Keyword Planner if I go back just gives
us low medium and high and if I I want
to compare numbers to numbers maybe I
want to be able to get exactly the
competition number for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
what I can do is go into Google and I
can type in that keyword so if I type in
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist I can see there's
76 Million results so I could see 76
Million results 76.1 actually and for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30 per month on average and so what
I want to do is get a more clear picture
of the competition and so what you could
actually do is type in the syntax all in
title and then colon and then your
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist and when I do that
I get a different result here I can see
only 136
listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136 with that particular
keyword that we want to rank for in the
title tag okay so the title tag is what
you see when you type in a keyword or
search query in Google search and the
title tag is what you see at the top of
every search result and so now I can see
I typed in how to become a digital
marketing specialist with the all
entitled syntax and now I can see every
listing every one of these 136 results
have that particular keyword in it so I
could see every one of them how to
become a digital marketing specialist
and why is that important because now
that tells me I only need to climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from Google's
Keyword Planner but you want to get your
competition from Google search and again
that's simply typing in the the syntax
all in title and then your keyword in
this example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page SEO so
again you want to
great content for say a keyword like
digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use Google search see first
when they type type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page SEO it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in Google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
Google will truncate the title tag so if
I go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag Google
trunk handed it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword in the title tag and
somebody types in that keyword then
chances are it's going to be relevant
they're going to see it and they're
going to click through to your website
and that's the whole idea behind ranking
we want to get clicks so that's how the
title tag appears so when you optimize
it you're going to update the title tag
and this is how it shows up it's going
to show up at the top of your listing
okay and it's going to be bigger and
Bolder than anything else Google
displays so the second thing you want to
optimize is the meta description and The
Meta description is simply just a brief
description up to 155 I would say about
155 to 60 160 characters but probably no
more than that and so the meta
description is nothing more than a
summary of the web page itself so if I
go back to my Google search results I
see my title tag and I see the page that
this particular listing belongs to and
underneath that is where I can see my
meta description so in this particular
keyword query how to become a digital
marketing specialist I see the meta
description an ultimate guide on how to
build a career in digital marketing and
the skills required to become a digital
marketing specialist note that it's a
well-written meta description within 155
characters and it includes the keyword
digital marketing specialist so we're
trying to rank for how to become a
digital marketing specialist and here
you can see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description and the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave The
Meta description blank then you're
leaving it to Google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
SEO we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the URL and URL stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the URL so
important because that's what people see
so if I go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the URL also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
URL is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's is relevant to the keyword query
and that's important for the end user
and Google Google wants to know hey is
this the page that's relevant to the
user's query and if it is then this user
is likely going to have a good X user
experience after they click on the
listing so the URL is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
URL structure doesn't help at all
because not only does Google not
recognize the URL as being relevant but
the end user may not want to click on
that page given the the way the URL
looks so you want to try and avoid a
poor URL structure so the rule of thumb
is this if you don't understand what the
URL is then Google is likely not going
to understand what the URL is and so we
want to try and keep our URL structures
clean and when I say clean ideally you
want to make sure that whatever keywords
you're trying to optimize that's the key
word that's in included in the URL
nothing included that is not
understandable so again going back to
our example how to become a digital
marketing specialist it's very clean the
title tag is the keyword The Meta
description is cleanly written has the
keyword and then the URL is the other
element that the end user can see and
that URL includes the keyword in it so
after we've done those three elements
the title tag The Meta description and
the URL then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organization relational
structure to the content and with
headers there's a hierarchy so you have
anywhere from H1 which is the top of the
hierarchy to an H6 and so you're free to
use any one of those headers when
building on a page in order to organize
the content but ideally you probably
want to stick with an H1 or an H2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to Google that hey this
header with this particular keyword in
it is important so if you use an H6 with
the keyword in it it's telling Google
hey this is an H6 but it's not as
important so an H1 and an H2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you
could see an H1 is going to be at the
top of the hierarchy so that means it's
going to be bigger and Bolder then you
have an H2 which is going to be bigger
and Bolder than an H3 but not as big and
bold as an H2 so with headers not only
are you organizing the content 10
accordingly but you're also signaling to
Google how important that particular
header is and of course the header needs
to include the keyword we're trying to
rank for so let's take a look again at
that example so if we go to how to
become a digital marketing specialist if
I click on that page I can look at the
content and I can see that there are
headers in here so the headers are there
to organize the content and that's what
we want we want to be able to organize
the content and if you look at the other
example I'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist a learning
path Explorer you can see that's an H1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an H2 and so we're not stressing to
Google that that's more important than
nh1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
Google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to Google
what's important and also to organize
the content because Google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal link and if you remember
earlier in the presentation it's
basically links from one page on your
website to another and so here we can
see on this particular article how to
become a digital marketing specialist
there's also links to other pages on
simply learns website and so for this
particular content it also links to SEO
specialist PPC specialist social media
marketing specialist and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their web website that
are relevant to becoming a digital
marketing specialist and so this is a
best practice when you're optimizing a
web page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and the
whole idea behind internal linking is it
also allows users to navigate through
the site naturally so when I say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation
thinking naturally and seamlessly go
from one relevant article or page to
another and so that's the whole idea
behind link building and internal link
building it allows Google to identify
you know pages that they want to crawl
and index because they're linked to one
another but it also helps the end user
because it allows the end user to go
from one page to another and it's
signaling to Google hey this particular
page is linked to this page so we're
going to also index that page and so
that's the whole important part of
internal linking it's about the end you
user experience and it's about allowing
Google to find the pages on your website
so they can crawl them and index them so
you can be ranked for them and so also
in addition to internal linking we want
to be able to use natural language and
so what do I mean by natural language or
natural language processing so what
Google does is in terms of natural
language processing they're looking for
the content and the keyword it needs to
be relevant so when your website is
about digital marketing you don't
necessarily want to rank or try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing one
it's too broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the key
keyword digital marketing maybe we want
to talk about the types of digital
marketing or digital marketing and
examples or what is a digital marketing
strategy or how to become a digital
marketing specialist so those are all
relevant keywords to digital marketing
and more relevant to the content because
if you try to rank for the keyword
digital marketing again it's probably
going to be a little bit broad probably
more competition and not as relevant to
your content and as a result probably
not a good user experience so think
about some other keywords that you could
optimize and rank for and that goes back
to the keyword research that's why the
keyword research is so important because
it allows us to identify other keywords
and the natural language process what
keywords are more relevant for the
content and then another element to
on-page SEO is the sitemap and so with
the sitemap it's basically a list of all
the pages on your website and the whole
idea of listing all the pages on your
website in one document is it helps both
users and search engines understand the
structure of your website so there are
two types of sitemaps one's an HTML
sitemap and that's designed for humans
so if you have a website with a lot of
content at the footer or the bottom of
your web page you probably want to have
a link to sitemap so if somebody clicks
on that side map they're going to be
able to see all the pages on your
website structured in an organized
manner well an XML sitemap an XML is
just a different format it's designed
for crawlers and so the whole idea
remember is Google likes to crawl
content when they crawl content they
bring it back to their servers and index
it and so we want to be able to create a
sitemap for Google or other search
engine crawlers and so XML is the format
so let me show you example of how that
looks so if I go to simplylearn.com and
simply we type in say sitemap.xml just
as an example I'm going to get this
particular page in this particular page
displays two XML sitemaps so these site
maps are there for Google to go ahead
and crawl and nothing more than a list
of all the pages on your website and so
this is a quick and easy way for Google
to get a hold of all those pages so that
they can index them and that's the whole
idea behind SEO you want to be able to
have Google index all the content you
want to be found for for the keywords
you want to be found for so it all
starts with the sitemap so let's go from
on-page SEO which in recap is basically
optimizing certain elements on your
website so that you are relevant for a
particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag The Meta
description the URL the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having internal linking gain and
also updating the sitemap well those are
elements that you can do on your website
so we're going to switch gears and talk
about a different strategy off-page SEO
because without on page or off page you
can't have a page ranking so the two
work together so you can do as much as
you want on on page but you still need
off-page SEO and you could do all the
off-page SEO you want but you still need
on page so both of these strategies have
to be in full effect in order for you to
rank so let's now switch gears to
off-page SEO and so off-page SEO is
simply the process of linking or
promoting your website using link
building and so if you remember I talked
about this earlier on there's two types
of links internal and external linking
and so for on-page SEO we used internal
linking for off-page SEO we're going to
talk about external linking and external
linking allows us to improve our website
sites recognition or relevancy or
credibility and why do we want to
improve our relevancy and credibility
and trustworthiness and Authority
because we want Google to know that our
web page is trustworthy it is recognized
by other websites and it is relevant for
a particular keyword and so if we can do
that using off-page SEO methods then
Google's going to rank our web page for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really off-page SEO synonymous with
link building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building it
just comes down to creating a strategy
so again some of the benefits to off
page well we talked about you know being
credible and trustworthiness and
relevant we need to do that in order to
rank but there's some other benefits
there so if we're have a link on another
credible website then it's likely going
to increase the traffic to our own
website it also creates high domain
Authority and so what I mean by high
domain Authority is if we have basically
links to other web pages pointing back
to us then basically our domain
Authority is going to improve and when
our domain Authority improves other
websites are going to want to link to us
so the higher authoritative we are for
our website than other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain Authority so it all starts
with linking to other high domain
Authority websites so linking to a high
domain Authority website for example
having a link on Wikipedia that points
back to our web page creates high domain
Authority for us and it helps Drive
traffic so some of the other benefits of
off-page SEO are incredibility so if
we're linking from Wikipedia to our web
page it does create credibility for us
it also helps us increase our page rank
so remember that external linking helps
build domain Authority helps build
credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page SEO link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high Authority
websites Wikipedia or say a social
platform it's going to increase our
brand awareness and increasing our brand
awareness increases our trustworthiness
and so if somebody is looking to say
become a digital marketing specialist
then likely instead of typing in digital
marketing Specialists on Google they may
type in our brand name in this case
simply learn and so these are all the
benefits to off-page SEO so it's nothing
more than having links on other websites
that are pointing back to ours and again
there's lots of benefits its drives
helps Drive traffic and increases our
Authority so those are things that we
want to take advantage of when we want
want to rank and the key behind off-page
SEO or link building is always going to
be content so from an on-page SEO
perspective having quality content
allows that content to be optimized for
Relevant keyword and ranked but also
from an off-page SEO strategy having
high quality content allows us to have
other sites and it doesn't necessarily
have to be a website it could be a
social platform or can be another
blogging platform or blogging website
link back to ours why because the
content is original it's natural it's
well structured it reads well and so
that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off-page SEO is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to spend a lot of
time or a bit of time on others websites
so remember the example I used earlier
in this presentation about having an ice
cream blog and ice cream recipes well it
probably wouldn't be a bad idea to say
spend some time on other blogs related
to desserts related to cakes related to
food in general related to vegetables or
other items that some people could link
from so the whole idea is understanding
who else is out there who has relevant
content that you could share so you
could share your content with them they
can share their content with you and
generally that's how it works naturally
anyway in the web sphere if somebody
likes your content they're going to link
to it they don't necessarily have to
wait for you to ask them but it might
not be a bad idea to understand who else
is out there that has content someone or
yours so that you can you know get a
link on that particular website or blog
post and so some other ideas behind
having external links pointing back to
your website is social media so social
media is not just Facebook or Twitter
here but it expands beyond that there's
there's core there's media there's all
sorts of content generated websites like
Reddit so the list goes on and on you
just need to find what's relevant for
your content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your end user experience if you add
somebody who has a say a Blog about
cakes having their link on your blog
post so there's nothing wrong with it
because it also adds to the user
experience and if you're going to ask
somebody to put an external link on
theirs you might want to be open-minded
and make sure that you're are able and
willing to put an external link on your
blog post or website pointing to their
content that's how the web Works
especially if the contents of quality
relevant and of good nature okay so
let's move on and finish up with the
do's and don'ts of SEO so we talked a
lot about why SEO what is SEO how do we
rank for SEO what is on page SEO what is
off-page SEO and so let's just wrap up
with some of the things you again want
to do to rank your page for a particular
keyword and some of the things you don't
want to do so the first thing on the
list is optimize for white hat
techniques and what I mean for opting in
for white hat techniques is basically
everything I just mentioned today you
want to do keyword research you want to
choose a natural language processing
form format so you could choose keywords
that are going to be relevant natural to
the content and you don't want to opt
for black cat techniques and blad hat
techniques are probably not even worth
going into detail but one example is
choosing a keyword arbitrarily like say
digital marketing and just stuffing that
keyword into the content so that's
probably not something you want to do
because again it's not going to be good
for the end user so stay away from black
hat and focus on some of the techniques
we talked about in today's presentation
the other do we want to do is get
backlinks from relevant sites so that's
off-page SEO again it's what I mentioned
earlier it's about linking your quality
content to another person's website that
also has quality content we don't want
to have a backlink from an irrelevant
site why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
Authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then Google's
going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in this same
way as if you were on a quality website
we do want to use our keywords naturally
because title tags are what people see
first on organic search but you don't
want to use the same title tag on every
page of your website so we want to stay
away from doing that so you want to have
a unique title tag for every web page on
your website and ideally what does that
mean that means using our keyword
research to choose one or two keywords
per page and optimizing your web page
for those one to two keywords so you
ideally what you want to do is have one
to two different keywords for every page
on your website we definitely definitely
definitely want to write engaging
content so the content should be
engaging remember user experience we
want users to stay on our website we
want them to enjoy the content that
they're reading and we want them to go
from one page to another naturally we
definitely don't want to leverage or
plagiarize or just copy content from
others websites because it's not one
probably going to be relevant to what
you're writing about two it's duplicate
content and it's somebody else's so
that's a black cat Technique we want to
stay away from I can't emphasize this
enough we need to do keyword research
first before you do anything else you
need to find relevant keywords and not
only that you need to understand the
volume and the competition for each of
those keywords okay you don't want to
choose a key word that has low volume
High competition you want to choose a
keyword that has high volume low
competition but above all you want to
choose keywords that are relevant to
your content we want to avoid keyword
stuffing so don't take a keyword and
just stuff it everywhere on the page
it's not going to be natural and
Google's going to be able to pick up on
that so we want to maintain some level
of quality with our content and quality
with the keyword that we choose so
reminder when you have quality content
it's always going to link internally to
another page on your website with
quality content but it's got to be
natural and don't just build site-wide
backlinks meaning don't just have an
internal link to the home page or don't
have every page on your website linking
to just one page so internal linking
should be natural naturally linking from
one page to another not only does it
help Google understand and crawl all the
web pages on your website but it's good
for the end User it's good user
experience and certainly last but
something I didn't talk about does take
time to rank your content so remember
the process you're going to write your
content you're going to choose keywords
you're going to change the elements on
that page for those keywords and all the
while you're going to make sure Google
can crawl that content and when they
crawl they're going to index it the
process to takes time especially if you
choose a keyword that's competitive so
just be patient if you have quality
content and you've optimized for on-page
SEO and off-page SEO then you will rank
for that keyword and then make sure your
website's user friendly and mobile
friendly so we talked about responsive
content earlier so remember most users
today start the process of search on
mobile so we want to make sure your
websites are mobile friendly well to get
this conversation started here's a
preview of what Matt will be talking
about today keyword research and search
Trends SEO friendly copywriting content
optimization website and landing page
optimization content Trends analytics
and of course we'll be answering your
questions throughout so feel free to
chime in so with that I would just like
to hand the mic over
for a bit here to to matte so take it
away Mr Bailey all right well thank you
Dan and as you can tell by the agenda it
seems to be content heavy and that is
certainly uh without an accident there
that if you've been in SEO for any
length of time you can see where things
are moving in the digital marketing
industry or social media content
marketing those types of things and so
the role of the SEO is becoming more
critical than ever in being that
connection from what are people
searching for and then what do we
publish SEO is that critical link
between the research and the development
of content and that is only going to
increase more and more over the next few
years so that's why there's a little bit
more emphasis on that content side that
you'll see there
but just you know a little bit more in
detail on that that the role of SEO has
primarily been as that first line of
understanding what the search engine is
doing what do they require what are the
new technologies coming out of search
and what are the trends coming from
search how is Google changing results
what are they testing so seos first and
foremost are on those front lines of
seeing what especially Google Google is
pushing the the envelope more than
anybody and they're testing more things
and so understanding what is Google
doing what are the implications of it is
this just a test or are we moving what's
the bigger picture of what they're
attempting to do
and so understanding that role there of
being that early predictor of what's
going on with Google and then being able
to translate that inside your
organization or inside your agency that
is really becoming part of you know the
the representative role of the search
engine Optimizer is understanding here's
what's happening and here's how we're
supposed to react to it
at the very base level it's
understanding those keywords it's
understanding what are people searching
for and what is their intent and how do
we then apply that into our content
strategy so that has been really kind of
the foundational part of what an SEO
does but it's also going to be a little
bit larger into looking at the larger
trends of what is Google attempting to
do what are the implications and how do
we respond to that
now of course with part of that keyword
research is understanding the long-term
trends uh over a year two years three
years because if something has a trend
and it's predictable well then that's
something you can bring into your
organization uh because I I love to say
if it's predictable it's monetizable you
can make money off it if you know that
it's going to happen every year because
you can prepare for it you can help your
organization prepare for those increases
in traffic especially if you're able to
tie those Trends into specific events if
you can come up with causality what
causes those to happen how do we react
to it how can we develop that and how
can we incorporate that into our
strategy again that is more of a
planning and prospecting work that a
search engine Optimizer would do and
those skills of doing keyword research
and understanding the long-term view of
keyword research of Trends throughout
the year creating those connections that
is a valuable skill which is only going
to increase
and of course those keywords are
important for anyone in a marketing
field or also customer service we've
seen more and more of this cross
marketing view across an organization
where marketing is getting more involved
in customer service they're getting more
involved in loyalty they're getting more
involved in many different aspects of
nurturing customers the customer
experience and so whenever you're
planning any of these things for social
media and what are we doing with social
media are we educating are we rewarding
are we trying to look for new customers
well all of that requires content that
content is going to have to be
researched as to when do we talk about
certain things and how do we talk about
certain things keyword research gives
you that agenda it keyword research
tells you when people search for certain
content and also the associate words
that they have and so that applies to
your content marketing your social media
marketing it also applies to when people
become customers and if you do any
amount of CRM marketing email marketing
or email automation or even triggered
your keyword research can help in
developing the content that will be in
those emails because you'll have done
the research and find out what do people
want after they make a decision after
they purchase a product what are the
needs that they have what is the
information need that they have and how
do we write towards that so again SEO is
influencing the content that is
generated by the entire organization in
nearly all Communications
this gets back to seeing the trends that
are happening within the search engine
and you've probably seen this lately I
love this example here so if I want to
make a latte and I type that into Google
uh this is what's interesting the answer
to my question is at the top of the page
now without even going to the website I
can have my answer
for the question and now there's a
couple implications to this
yes it's great we can be at the top of
the rankings we can have our answer
there but if the answer completely
answers the searcher's question
it doesn't generate a page view they
don't see much of our brand they aren't
in really they aren't engaging with us
at all they're engaging with Google and
so this gets to the point of how do you
then bring this to the organization as
far as a strategic view of this how do
we approach it how does this change what
we do with our website or with our
content
you can also see here that people are
asking different questions and this gets
to the copywriting of the website are
you generating content that answers
questions because this is where Google
is pooling this information as well as
pooling the related questions that come
from that type of content
this also is critical because this then
leads into voice search and so if you've
got a home assistant uh you use any of
the phone assistance or hey guess what
this is coming in cars that you will
have a voice assistant in cars and your
search result will be read back to you
and this is the beginning stages of that
that if you have a question or a search
you would speak your search and then the
first result would be read back to you
and as you can see it's not coming from
the site it's coming from Google so this
is where again we sit down we look at
the strategy what are we trying to do
what is our strategy as far as
visibility in the search results and
what's going to happen and what's
happening now with this is you could be
answering people's questions and never
knowing it simply based because Google
is delivering the result they're not
going to your site now the possibility
of them going to your site exists but as
more voice searches are being generated
Google is going to deliver a result that
doesn't require a click through because
it's all happening through audio
so hopefully this uh doesn't uh all the
changes in SEO I would say over the past
uh 15 years have been largely external
driven by Google as Google has taken
away keywords taken away uh keywords and
analytics done numerous things here that
have caused seos to have to react and
again this is one of those changes that
causes us to sit and figure out how are
we going to deal with this change we
have some questions already one of which
is Google's not spending so much time
focusing on keywords specifically even
though they're still important where do
you suggest the marketers look for
keywords
oh I think the the typical keyword
research tools are still very viable in
fact you'll probably get uh better
information out of keyword tools than
you will Google's keyword Tool uh Google
has been combining keyword Concepts
under a single keyword so for example
um a great one that uh we've seen in the
keyword research uh pool table and pool
tables plural and singular Google puts
that all under pool table whereas anyone
who you know does any amount of
e-commerce can tell you there is a world
of difference between people that search
for plural and singular uh before the
the changes in keywords I could tell you
with numerous sites that we had that if
people searched with the singular
version uh they were about three to five
times more likely to purchase than if
they searched for the plural version uh
the plural version meant that they were
shopping the singular version pointed to
they were ready to make a decision
so Google won't show you the data
however between the plural and singular
for pool tables some other keyword
research tools however will show you
that so even though you know even though
it's getting more difficult with the
keywords from a marketing standpoint
absolutely still do your keyword
research right as if you would uh you
know you're gonna have to do additional
research maybe you know customer
research uh you know face to face asking
them to describe how they would search
or what they were looking for or what
problem you solved because you're going
to need a wider variety of input for
keywords yeah and if you have any way to
look into your competitors I know there
are some tools that let you let you do
that you can see what your competitors
are or at least in their or their sem
you can learn a lot yes because uh you
can you can tell a lot by what's a
valuable keyword by learning what your
competitors are paying for and also
check your kicker analytics to see how
people are actually finding you uh
what's interesting is how is uh how is
your brain I know the rank brain is is
one of the most influential parts of
Google now and I know that that's
basically a lumping instead of creating
separate pages for plurals and
other iterations of words rank brain is
a sort of uh including all of that and
looking for those words in general
content is that how is rank brain
affecting uh Search terms and and SEO
with just keywords
um you know it's it's really trying to
learn more of what exactly do people
want uh from an intentional standpoint
uh so trying to put together
uh unfamiliar searches or unfamiliar
phrasings or I think I read the other
day
um I'm trying to think whose name it was
but it was oh Matthew McConaughey his
name in one week had
like 8 000 misspelled variations
uh so somehow you know a search engine
has to figure out over 8 000
misspellings who did you mean you know
who are you trying to figure out
um you know so it's it's trying to
figure out the intent and deliver the
right result and you know I think part
of this is yes they don't want seos to
be focusing on individual words
[Music]
um
and by taking away all that data you
know in a way they have accomplished
that
uh so you know what rankbrain is
attempting to do is trying to tie those
things together of how do we figure out
now they're looking at the minutia of
the difference of words but they do not
want to show it to us right so there's
not a whole lot you can do with it it's
just you know it's from their standpoint
the best thing you can do is just
continue to write
great content that people want that
answers their questions using a variety
of
using a variety of words that explain uh
you know a great example is you know if
you're writing an article uh you know
baseball season started here in the U.S
if you're reading an article about
baseball you're going to use words like
umpire like balls strikes bats teams
those are all words that build context
and so
they're going to count just as much as
the primary term baseball and in fact
Google's going to look for all those
other terms that that build that context
and so it's it's not so much that single
word anymore it's that variety of I
would call those second tier words that
support the context of what you're
writing about rows are coming more into
play yeah and and of course putting that
in a in a more natural language type of
uh type of phraseology in your content
rather than just the old days of
keywords how many keywords can we stuff
in the first paragraph uh what's the
optimum number of words in the in the
meditation I mean because now it really
if it looks like you're I mean this
Google's been penalizing people for
doing stuff like that for years but now
especially with rank brain the the more
you can do to look to write like a
conversation that people are actually
thinking and asking about I'm sure is a
better way they've always wanted that I
mean that has always been Google's goal
from the beginning they have told us to
write for humans uh but the problem has
been you know there are a lot of seos
there that would rather take the
formulaic approach and
you know why should I write for humans
I'm just trying to get people to my site
you know I want they're gonna buy uh and
so they you know try to reverse engineer
everything to come up with this formula
of use this keyword this many times in
this part of the page and you know
whereas Google has always said right for
humans first and so by taking away some
of those other options or taking away
the keywords it's really guided the
industry to do what they wanted to do
and honestly I think it's it's a good
thing because the quality of content has
to increase it has to get better uh and
that is one way that they've enforced
that what exactly what they've imposed
their will on on people who desire to
have better rankings right the uh I just
have one one more question that people a
lot of people are asking if you have any
specific recommendations for for keyword
research tools before we allow there are
a lot of them
um so if you've got like Raven or
um trying to think what are some of the
others Raven SEO tools
um there's one right on the edge of my
tongue um
word tracker yeah
um
oh I've got a list of them somewhere
here
yeah
just look
did research tools
um there are a lot of them many of them
offer free trials and so yeah just get
in do the free trial take a look at
what's there
um yeah yeah some come with full service
site management you may not want all
that you may you may want that others
are more Standalone independent they
just do keyword research never choose a
keyword research tool that doesn't show
up at least on page 10 of the serps
but yeah and
and the more you do keyword research I I
have always felt this way and it's it's
the more you do keyword research the
better equipped you are to do your job
uh and and by that it's dissecting the
keywords what are people looking for
what are the trends what do they
associate what are uh the people places
and things so as you're looking at the
keywords you're not so much looking to
see the volume that someone searched for
you know by uh you know buy a pink car
that's that's a great you know that's
good but they talked about cars they
talked about buying and they talked
about color that's more what we're
looking for is let's start slicing and
dicing this down what words are they
associating what colors what uh features
and by understanding the breadth of how
people search and the questions they
have it helps you write better content
because now you understand not just
sacrificing for one word people have
questions across an entire breadth of
type style color uh Place uh City uh you
know all these types of things and so
that's really what I challenge people to
get out of keyword research is
understanding the full breadth of what
people want rather than just a single
word or a single phrase this gets into
copywriting you see like I said when you
when you get into you know are people
looking for colors are there people
looking for locations sizes I want to
understand the breadth of what they're
talking about and that helps me become a
better copywriter I can understand
intent if I know the questions that they
have then we can write answers and so
you know I want to see how people are
searching you know a great example is is
now we've seen searches increasing for
people searching for you know the best
or the top rated or
oh yeah for me uh people are actually
typing in what is the best car for me
and I think what they're doing
essentially is is directly asking Google
you know based on the two million things
you know about me what would be the best
car for me
um so people are looking for more
personalized information uh so what you
can do is get into the you know the how
to the why the you know what it means
all these different cues that people are
giving in their key phrases develop your
content to answer those questions yeah I
had actually seen a statistic that 82
percent of smartphone users use and this
is for businesses oh we're looking for
businesses use specifically the term
near me after their research so even
geographically
um I don't know if that's anything you
can include in the content but uh well
no you know it's it's blows my mind
because
um if they're on their smartphone
they're automatically going to get
results near them uh that that's kind of
interesting so it's more of a cue for
Google than it is for a website because
to use that phrase in any of your
optimization really wouldn't make a lot
of sense
uh because you don't know who's near you
um and if anything especially on a
mobile search Google is pretty much
going to ignore that near me because
you're going to get the results near
where you are anyway
yeah um so yeah getting into the search
data people search for what they need
they they figure out what they're
looking for but now here is where the
role of the SEO is going to come in
organizationally is that when you have
people writing content generating
content for Content marketing for social
media uh especially if you're working
with uh you know like a publisher who is
constantly developing content now you
need to help them come up with ways to
measure success
and also to motivate them to implement
SEO tactics in their writing so rather
than developing catchy headlines uh that
may have a double meaning that may not
play well in search you need to help
copywriters understand that well your
headline while that might look great on
print in search it's actually going to
cause a problem and so you turn into an
educator for your content developers uh
you're teaching them what works well
what's going to click well what's going
to look well in the search engines
versus what might be confusing
also uh it's also helping them to
understand you know a great example of
this um before I move on someone
um gave me a great example is they were
writing an article about holiday time
travel and that was the title of the
article that they put out there and they
couldn't figure out why this article was
consistently getting hundreds or
thousands of visits a month uh well
after it was published and when we went
back and started looking at some of the
rankings and some of the keywords and
things like that we found out that the
article was ranking really well for time
travel uh even though the headline was
holiday time travel uh so it's helping
your writers understand
um you know what makes a good title uh
but then also one thing that I worked
with one publisher and one of the things
we did to motivate the writers was to
develop like a a leaderboard of whose
content is generating the most visits uh
and not only that whose content is
generating the most new visits to the
website and then you you can carry that
through to you know for how for
different writers how many visits or
views have you generated in a month or
over the past six months how much is
your content uh performed compared to
other content and you can carry this all
the way out to you know which writers
had the highest amount of AD clicks uh
in their articles uh which articles uh
led to people to uh
subscribe again or you know even get
into customer lifetime value uh there's
so many things that you could Implement
so from an SEO standpoint you understand
already how to look at the success of
game rankings and what it generates in
terms of page views click-throughs time
on site uh click depth uh you know all
those types of things that you can then
develop into helping others in the
organization who publish content start
to measure the m impact of their writing
organizationally and then especially if
you're able to tie that to a financial
implication
that shows that this is what it's
contributing towards the business in
terms of Revenue then you become the
all-around hero because you're able to
help others tie Revenue to activity
that's great we have someone asking can
this backfire on you for example if
you're starting every headline with one
weird this one weird trick dot dot dot
if you find that you have a lot of if
your bounce rate immediately starts
going up yeah you have because if you're
waiting for time travel or Star Wars or
something uh that everyone's going to be
looking for
then
could that actually negatively affect
how Google sees you if it's if you have
all these bounce rates they might see
you as uh no longer being relevant
absolutely and it's not just Google with
the bounce rate it damages your brand it
damages your credibility I mean it's
it's clickbait and I mean it doesn't
take long for people to realize
clickbait is clickbait
um you can just look at some of the data
uh but yeah I mean when you see articles
or headlines that are obvious click bait
people are you know you get caught a
couple of times you get fooled a couple
of times it's not always going to work
and so this gets to
you know how are you positioning your
brand are you positioning your brand as
a trustworthy source of information that
answers people's questions are you
positioning your brand as we give people
what they need what they want uh or are
you fooling them to click on an article
based on what's popular right now uh you
know there's a couple questions that get
to how the brand wants to be perceived
in the marketplace uh based on tactics
like that
but great question great question
because clickbait is powerful
um but you've got to ask yourself are we
giving people what they want or are we
fooling them into it and how will that
reflect on the brand
right
uh from another keyword standpoint one
thing that I found is very valuable to
do is go out and look and see how people
are searching for the brand and content
associations they make with that brand
now this can also get into other areas
you may find that there's some crossover
uh where there's another company with a
similar brand name and so this will help
you understand a little bit more if you
get some of that crossover traffic but
also from a PR standpoint do people
associate content or ideas with your
brand that you would wrap this will help
you become aware of something that might
be out there that may not be getting
picked up uh so I I enjoy doing these
kinds of searches because I want to know
what other words associations are people
making with the brand right that you may
need to deal with
yeah and also look at your analytics and
what is linked in your CRM to see uh how
people have actually converted because
if you have some long tail keywords in
there that would be good to generate
content on uh that your best customers
are finding you through that can be
super valuable and least compensate for
having some super clickbaity
work and just keep in there accidentally
what's interesting is that people people
are are a few people are really wanting
to hone in on this uh
backtrack a bit here to ways to
capitalize on certain things that
um I know people are looking for quick
answers to rank high on Google but the
question keeps coming up about for
example are there any ways why you could
restructure your content to capitalize
on things like near me like should you
put in your opening paragraph you know
if you're looking for a near
that's that's almost I I personally
would would shrink from doing that
because I know that that's something
that that seems that a Google I don't
want to put words on your map it seems
like hey Google is already doing that
automatically based on if you're
searching mobile but two if pretty soon
they're going to catch up to people
putting best and near me and because
that's the other question like should I
should I use terms that are when I when
I see the results of the most commonly
searched terms and mobile should I put
those in my in my copy so what do you
say about that like are there ways to
that you can legitimately without being
uh penalized capitalized yeah well okay
if you're legitimately publishing an
article that is well researched
comparing different products and you
title it best pet food products or
something like that that's a legitimate
case I have no problem with that do your
homework and create something of value
and it will do well if it's good content
that people like now the the near me is
a bit more sketchy because even though
you may put on your website something
about near you or near me
uh not everyone who visits your website
remember this is more of a mobile
uh phenomenon these are people on their
phone looking for something near them a
drugstore uh a car wash uh you know
something like that a restaurant and
that's being computed based on distance
based on uh you know past preferences
things like that
so it has nothing to do with the content
of your website what I would work on
more is your local business listing in
Google
and developing more reviews for your
business and working with that uh
listing to add more pictures like I said
reviews uh
they have a function there now where you
can add promotions the more you develop
that Google listing that will do a
hundred times more to increase your
visibility when someone is looking for
something near them and they are near
you
than adding words to your website great
well that's not smart
across a bit forcefully on some of these
things
because I it's it's
it has never bothered me when people out
and Out Try to fool Google with some
really intelligent things uh I I
somewhat tend to admire it uh but when
people try to fool Google with what I
would call amateurish things that are
poorly executed that's where I S you
know that's where I get
I get a little ticked off at that
because it's
create a quality experience that's what
people want
quality experience uh and and that's
really what it gets down to with you
know we with content marketing you're
answering people's questions and so as
people are generating that content
you're also sending them back to the
site you're sending them back to get
answers to register to do things like
that so all those web pages from the
content marketing that they're linking
to they need to be optimized for your
inbound strategy
and what's interesting is also from a
paid search standpoint the landing page
from Paid search you know it needs to be
optimized just like any other page
that's part of the quality score
algorithm does the landing page reflect
the paid search headline does it also
contain the keyword that you're bidding
on so
you've got to look at how people are
developing their landing pages
internally and maybe you can contribute
to that as well in helping improve the
quality score because the optimization
of that landing page is very similar
uh where I see employment and Industry
Trends now this is interesting because
talking with the uh director of omcp and
some of the surveys he's been doing of
hiring managers HR managers and
Technology
uh or in marketing across the across the
the globe here one of the things that he
has seen is there is becoming more
demand of people who can manage the
entire Tech marketing stack not the
single Channel Specialists because more
and more automation is handling that uh
more and more you know and this is where
we're going to see the entrance of AI
and machine learning is adjusting your
paid search campaign with those minute
methods of increasing your click-through
rate uh you know it's going to be
managing those bids So eventually you're
just going to focus more on the content
and eventually AI is going to take over
the content uh so the demand is for who
were the single Channel Specialists of
SEO paid search social to move into
understanding the entire omni-channel
digital marketing campaign and can run
and can change and can make
recommendations across the board for the
entire stack of digital marketing this
is where we're seeing more of the
employment trends uh going as well as
the skills demand is getting away from
that single hard skill to understanding
the entire campaign
uh and that's going to go into all
different types of things that's going
to include email CRM social display uh
and seos I think are probably very well
positioned in all of these things
because of the foundation of keywords
the foundation of keywords and
understanding intent and then developing
content that answers those questions
that's needed an email it's needed in
automation it's needed in Social and
display you know especially in the CRM
automation is someone has to write the
content that needs to be automated and
so again this then gets into
uh looking at the trends uh because
automation you not only need to write
the content but you need to then plan
the content when is it sent when is this
completed when is this done uh and so
understanding the the sales cycles and
how long they go and when people need
certain information at what times it
takes that planning strategy of being
able to do that and I think seos are
well positioned to understand that full
stack of marketing and the implications
as well as the management of it
and then we get to analytics uh this is
my favorite
um
so as an SEO or if you're taking on more
of the the Omni Channel burden here uh
you've got to develop those measurements
that show how effective not only SEO has
been but now content management content
management is Big everyone is moving
towards it it has become a significant
piece of strategy however what is
lacking in content management is the
measurement how do we know that this
content piece that went out whether it
was a video uh whether it was an
infographic whether you know regardless
of what it was number one how do we
Track Performance number two how do we
know it affected anything number three
what was the pathway where were we
driving people and what did we want them
to do and how successful was that and
then also from an attribution standpoint
did this lead to other things you know
where did this content piece or where
does this channel help us overall an
attribution in driving New Leads or
nurturing people along the path and so
it's getting more than just getting you
know measuring clicks it's it's
measuring actual hard dollars that were
generated based off specific channels or
specific pieces of content uh and then
you know it's developing an
understanding of sales goals what did
the sales department need uh in terms of
information to enhance the CRM so that
they can nurture people along in the
path uh so it's more than just marketing
it's understanding that full scope that
a company has
yeah that's a it's an excellent point
and I think another thing to keep in
mind too is is use actual conversation
with your sales people oh as a one of
the few things it's funny that that
marketing and sales often are their own
little silos and yeah I I think one of
the best things a marketer can do is
just go and talk to your best sales
people and ask them
what why are people buying us uh what
what are the what are they what are the
questions they are asking you to answer
um I think that can be uh because those
questions since they're legitimately
people that are that are engaging with
your sales people and making purchases I
think those are the most valuable
questions you can answer in your copy oh
absolutely I mean short of talking to a
customer talking to your sales
department is the best way to get
information
um it now my before I got into SEO I was
in sales I took sales training and and
you know dealt directly with people so
it kind of
I had that uh uh you know that view of
things but I I'm amazed at how much
people don't interact with their sales
department in order to learn uh you know
what do people need how do we answer
their questions what you know what do
they respond to but then also your sales
people are the first in line entering
information into the CRM and when leads
are created through your marketing
efforts it'd be good to ask them what
additional information do you need that
would make a better lead
you know there and there are many times
where we have changed the site on the
recommendation of the sales team and you
know we we may not have it we didn't
improve conversions but we what we
improved were the the the scenario
through which the sales call then came
after the conversion and increased the
close rate just based on changing the
landing page or the thank you page after
the registration right and it's it's a
good conversation to start having with
your sales Fields who said that they
know what kind of questions to listen to
because a lot of times they're just not
paying attention you ask a salesperson
they made the sale because I was a great
sales guy
um but the more you the more you work
with them as a team and say that hey you
know to get them thinking about actually
listening to what the customers are
asking for and passing that on to you
um you know that of course will will
help lead attribution and and
all the things you said so yeah
definitely don't forget the human
element in SEO well and this gets to you
know this really gets to it
if the trend now is moving more towards
you know someone who can manage a full
stack it's also moving towards people
who understand how to align sales and
marketing goals and beyond that it's not
just you know like the example I gave
before it's not just okay we increase
the conversion rate of our registration
okay that's great what how did that
contribute to revenue but now it's
understanding that there are things that
we can do to increase a close rate that
don't always take place on the website
but it's a process and so now we're
analyzing processes that can be done
electronically and then how do we create
a better Revenue stream that way how do
we make a better nurture process now
we're getting into the effectiveness of
content and producing a result rather
than just you know a conversion uh a
sale or a lead now we're looking at well
how do we make more money based out of
this uh and that's really it's that big
picture of understanding that you know
our job is not just to get leads it's to
create better profitable ability which
rewards everybody
so it's understanding those touch points
from content uh you know so as content
is being pushed out does it answer the
question does it lead people to the next
stage how quickly does it lead them
there uh can you measure influence from
your content and you know through depth
of visitor to the depth of the page that
they got to
um and then again it's the experience
based on motivations can you understand
that can you tie together what a
customer was feeling at a specific point
through their nurture stream uh or
through this process as I said it's
getting away from more just stuff that
happens on the site it's Communications
throughout the entire process the entire
life cycle of a customer that's all
coming under the the management really
of the marketing team right now is that
entire customer life cycle communication
and management
uh and finally this is something a trend
that I've been seeing as well in terms
of uh jobs and hiring and also business
function uh omcp did a a survey at the
beginning of the year asking people
where they spent the most amount of
their time and specifically in SEO and
SEO managers uh and uh
anyone who dealt with SEO nearly 40
percent of their time was spent
uh presenting their research presenting
strategy as well as uh as well as
explaining their the reasoning for that
strategy and so seos you need to become
a lot more comfortable in front of
people uh presenting your findings
making recommendations presenting
opportunities Trends uh and presenting
it in a persuasive
format
that shows not a bunch of data charts
but shows how smart you are in creating
new Revenue opportunities for the
company
and that is really where we see a lot of
things going are the presentation skills
are becoming part of the demand for
companies when they're dealing with tech
if getting your learning started it's
half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit skillup by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more
keyword research so what are we going to
talk about when we talk about keyword
research we're going to talk about why
we would do keyword research for SEO
we're going to talk about the types of
keywords that we need to research we're
going to talk about some methodologies
best practices on how to do keyword
research some alternate suggestions
we're going to talk about keyword
clustering and then we're going to talk
about some tools that you can use to do
your keyword research so let's start
with the why we would do keyword
research so Jesse is planning to publish
a Blog of pizza recipes so she was doing
pizza recipe step by step piece of
recipes with sausage homemade pizza
toppings pizza dough recipes thin crust
pizzas she's doing a lot of different
topics on pizza recipes well what Jesse
needs to do is understand what's going
to drive traffic to these blog posts if
she's writing about you know different
topics around pizza recipe a piece so
she's Unsure how these blogs are going
to drive traffic so she really needs to
understand that hey you need to choose
the right keywords to drive traffic so
the question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keywords he is maybe
maybe not so you need to take uh care
and shoes in the queue words to align
with your content so that's really the
idea of why we would do keyword research
because some of the issues with key
words that are poorly chosen are they
can have low search volume for example
you may choose a keyword that just a lot
of people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very broad or
popular it can be very competitive and
take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyword that isn't
aligned with your content or you can
choose keywords but use them incorrectly
with your content so these are some of
the issues that you can encounter if you
just go about choosing keywords randomly
without due diligence without the proper
research so low search volume will lead
to less traffic High competition you may
not even rank at all okay if somebody
finds you for a keyword that's not
relevant to the topic they're just going
to leave the page and if you're not
using the right keywords and or if you
are using the right keywords and not
using them correctly in the content then
your pages may not even be found in
organic search so you really have to
take care and choosing the keywords to
me that's the most important step with
SEO is keyword research so we're going
to talk about the types of keyword
research then so we have short tail
keywords and we have long tail keywords
so if you write a blog post about pizza
recipes well what are you going to
choose a short tail or long tail so
let's talk about short-term care words
first so short tail keywords are
keywords that are usually three key
words in a phrase or shorter in some
cases it may be two key words in a
phrase or shorter so shortcut keywords
usually have high search volume which
means likely means higher competition
but what it also means it could be lower
conversions because short tell key words
like for example pizza recipes could be
considered a short tell key word but
maybe somebody's looking for homemade
pizza recipes or pizza recipes from
their favorite Italian restaurant so
short taking words may not be as
relevant so if we compare it with long
tail keywords chances are you're going
to have lower competition that's one of
the benefits but you're also gonna have
lower search volume but with longer tail
keywords the key word is probably going
to be more relevant with the content
you're writing about so therefore the
conversion rates likely going to be
higher so that's really the difference
between short-term keywords and long
tail keywords if you want to look at
simplistically short tail keywords are
Broad in nature it's going to capture a
lot of eyeballs but those eyeballs may
look at your content as not relevant
versus long tail K words that may be
very relevant but not as many eyeballs
on them so short tail keywords the
characteristics they're not as specific
usually they're less than three words
they have high search volume and high
competition so if you just choose pizza
recipes could take you a while to rank
for that keyword but when you rank
you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the key
word is Broad in nature so pizza recipes
is a short tail keyword that may not be
exactly what you're writing about in
your blog post so it may draw a lot of
traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
three words in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long take away
word is probably going to be greater
because not many other websites are
trying to rank for that same keyword and
so the benefit of that is if you have
let's just say homemade pizza recipes
with mushrooms that's a long 10 key word
but if somebody's looking for that type
of pizza recipe then you know you're
going to track the right traffic and
chances are that traffic is going to
engage or convert based on the type of
conversion you have in place so example
would be homemade pizza dough recipes
that'd be another example more than
thick keywords in the phrase very
specific we're talking about homemade
pizza dough recipe so we're not talking
about just pizza recipes so it's a
little bit more specific in nature
longer tail so these keywords are used
for targeted Pages including blog posts
if you're writing a blog post
specifically about pizza recipes with
homemade dough then this is the key word
you likely would want to use versus just
pizza recipes so let's look at an
example between a a short tail keyword
and a long tail keyword and to
accentuate the differences we're going
to use Google's Keyword Planner tool so
Google's keyboard Planner tool is
located in Google ads the Google ads
platform and when you're in the Google
ads platform you can simply click on
tools and then Keyword Planner and so
what Keyword Planner allows us to do is
get a sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what Google's
Keyword Planner does is they show you
the average monthly searches this is the
average monthly search volume of a
keyword over the past 12 months and so
in this example we're going to choose
pizza recipes and homemade pizza dough
recipes so one short sale and one long
tail so we enter those keywords in we're
going to click get results and what
Google's going to do is it's going to
show us the volume of those keywords so
for pizza recipe we could see the
average monthly search volume is thirty
three thousand one hundred for pizza
recipe so note that pizza recipe and
pizza recipes are closely related
keywords and so what Google does is they
consider that a close variance so
meaning if somebody ties a piece of
recipe then they're also in Google's
eyes looking for pizza recipes so it's a
close variance and so for the keyword
pizza recipe which is short tail we
could see on average over the past 12
months this keyword received 33 100
queries and so if we hover over the
graph we could see basically the volume
the average volume per month so here I
could see for this particular keyword
here the volume per month is 33 1000 and
then I can see the actual volume over
the past 12 months and then for the long
tail keyword I can see homemade pizza
dough recipe again close variance
homemade pizza dough recipes I can see
over the past 12 months what the search
volume is for this on average is 2400
but I could see here in December the
volume went up to 3600 but for example
in May it was 1900. so it's gonna
fluctuate a bit over the past 12 months
but on average it's about 2400. so
shorter tail a lot of more volume longer
tail not as much volume but nonetheless
there is volume here and so these are
the difference between a short tail and
a longer tail and said well Google's
Keyword Planner also does is allow us to
get a sense of what the competition is
and so here I can see the competition is
low for both of these keywords fair
enough so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know for ranked on page one of Google
even in the top spot we can expect about
2400 search queries for that keyword now
whether you get up 2 400 clicks for that
keyword remains to be seen chances are
you're not going to get all 2400 you're
going to get a Lion's Share of those
clicks but you're going to at least get
some volume on it so even the longer
take keywords have a lot of Promise
because there is some search volume here
for this keyword how to do a proper
keyword research so we looked at
Google's Keyword Planner tool and Google
ads and we typed in two keywords and we
were able to get a sense of what the
average volume is so we definitely want
to choose keywords based on the
following factors we want to choose it
based on search volume search volume is
a good indicator of the potential
traffic we can obtain so again for the
keyword homemade pizza dough recipe we
know that it averages 2400 a month in
search volume again we may not get all
2400 but we're gonna get a line share of
that we also need to look at competition
and so Google's Keyword Planner gives us
a high medium or low in terms of the
competition but if you're somebody who
wants to get a better sense of what the
competition is and you should because
competition is a key component in
choosing keywords and so what I want to
do is get a sense of how many people are
actually optimizing for that keyword so
Google's Keyword Planner tool is going
to give me a low medium high really what
I want to do is get a better sense of
that numerically so what I can do is go
into Google search and I could type in
pizza recipes and I could see there's
about 1 billion results that's a lot of
results however that means that every
potential web page out there on the
internet that mentions pizza recipes is
going to be included in this number here
and so I want to get a better sense of
who's optimizing for pizza recipes so
I'm going to put in the all in title
syntax and so what that is going to ask
Google to do is tell me all the websites
that have pizza recipes the keyword
pizza recipes in the title tag so if I
do all entitled colon space then pizza
recipes my result drops down to 336 000.
so what that tells me is that there are
000 results with the keyword pizza
recipes in the title tag now if I want
to focus in on my other keyword if I
choose my other keyword was a longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough recipe
so if I type that keyword in the
homemade pizza dough recipe or recipes
remember close variance and I just click
enter or type the keyword in hit my
Enter key I'm going to get 35 Million
results but again is that really an
indicator of the type of competition I
have no because every listing that
mentions homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so I'm going to type in my all
in title colon space and then I'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and I get
2160 different results so here I can see
the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites web pages that have that keyword
in the title tag so now I have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about SEO
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for SEO and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close Fair variance here
is pizza recipe what was the volume well
we know the volume was 33 100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 000 so I'm going to
type in 683
000. what was our next keyword well it
was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes so if I go back for this
particular keyword is 2400 so I'm going
to put 2400 in under my volume column
and then what was my competition well my
competition was I typed that keyword
back in
2160. so I'm going to put two thousand
one hundred and sixty so now I have an
idea of what kind of volume and what
kind of competition I have now you want
to do this for a number of different
keywords and when you do it for a number
of keywords what you do want to do is
obviously choose a relevant keyword that
has has high volume and low competition
so another way of saying it is the
volume or ratio of volume to competition
and so basically what we could do is
take volume divided by competition if I
make that a percentage I can see it's
0.35 percent is the ratio between volume
of competition if I do the same for my
longer tail keyword 2400 divided by 2160
I can see that 111 so this just kind of
proves the point that yeah I'm still
going to get some volume but I have a
better chance of ranking for this longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough
recipes so you want to be able to do
that for a number of keywords and
examine the volume the competition and
the ratio between volume and competition
for your themed keywords in this case
pizza recipes so relevancy you want to
choose keywords that are very relevant
to the content that you're writing and
then again commercial intent what
keywords are going to drive more
conversions and Revenue for the business
so when we talk about commercial intent
we're talking about you know are you
choosing keywords that are going to get
somebody to do what you want them to do
so we could say You Know download pizza
dough recipes so somebody's typing in
the keyword download pizza dough recipes
then chances are they're going to find
you come to your site and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the key word is it going
to help you drive conversions and
revenue if you're an e-commerce site so
search volume is the average monthly
search volume made for a particular
keyword and phrase so we can get that
number using Google's Keyword Planner
tool in the Google ads platform we want
to Target keywords with high search
volume that will help bring traffic to
the website we want volume but we want
to take into account seasonality as well
so that's where the Google's Keyword
Planner tool comes in place because if
we go back again we can just hover over
over we can get a sense of any
particular Trend going on or seasonality
so for example if I saw large growth in
the winter months and not much volume
growth in the summer months then that
might indicate to me that this keyword
is more popular during the winter time
so pay attention to the grass that you
know the Keyword Planner tool gives you
use them to your advantage to take into
account seasonality so a good example
would be funny Halloween costumes well
we know that for Halloween you're going
to have a spike probably towards the end
of September all the way through October
and then it's going to drop after
October 31st which is Halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are are choosing to search
for pizza recipes during maybe the
summer months versus the winter months
so pay attention to seasonality it will
affect search volume so competition
based on our example it's one of the
most important key metrics you don't
want to choose a keyword that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of Google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
Google's Keyword Planner tool to find
the volume we use the all entitled
syntax to find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always relevancy always
trumps ratio so always go with a key
word that is going to be relevant to
your content don't choose a keyword
that's not relevant if you choose a
keyword that's not relevant it's not
going to bode well for user engagement
so the difficulty of a keyword ranges
from 0 to 100 and Google's keyword tool
so it's going to be easy it's going to
be medium it's going to be hard but my
recommendation is also to get the
numerical factor and that's the all in
title syntax and again relevancy is what
drives the traffic to your website and
keep the traffic there on your website
and also not only will keep the traffic
on your website but hopefully get that
traffic to engage and convert so that's
the key about relevancy you always want
to choose keywords that are relevant to
your content even if it's sacrificing
volume relevancy again trumps volume and
competition so always choose relevant
keywords first so when you do that
you're always almost guaranteeing that
at some point somebody's going to find
your content because somebody out there
might be looking for it and if they do
you're going to get found and then the
engagement is going to be better so
understand your business find keywords
that are relevant to your business and
then focus on those keywords that'll
help you with getting the right traffic
to your site always keep in mind the
commercial intent so these keywords are
more specific and result in conversion
rate for example buying is a good
commercial intent keyword so if you
really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe it's download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there may be low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to drive to your site
so some other examples like commercial
intent keywords or discount deal your
coupon shipping you know don't be afraid
to use some of these keywords as part of
your longer till keyword phrase again
the volume may not be high but the
traffic quality is probably going to be
better so keyword research is the found
foundation for SEO so if you have chosen
your keywords properly then if you do
get ranked for those keywords then it's
going to lead to better engagement with
some conversions and so when we talk
about keywords we also want to talk
about our primary and secondary keyword
so every page should have at least a
primary keyword and then a second carry
keyword to work with so primary keywords
are really defining the nature of your
content the secondary keywords are
relevant to the primary keyword so why
do we choose a primary and secondary
keyword because you may choose a keyword
as a primary keyword that is relevant to
the content but may not necessarily rank
very high or have a lot of volume that's
secondary keyword is also relevant to
the primary keyword but also relevant to
content and you may rank for that
secondary keyword so you always want to
go with two keywords versus just one
keyword you want to give your yourself a
chance to rank for at least two
different types of keywords of relevant
nature so for web page there can be
several secondary keywords but only one
primary keyword so your primary keyword
is always going to be relevant to your
content secondary keywords can be
relevant to the keyword but and you may
have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary in search Okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if our primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
these secondary keywords are also
related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do is go to cool Google's Keyword
Planner tool and get an idea of the
volume for healthy diet plan and then
also the volume and competition for some
of these secondary keywords like healthy
diet for weight loss healthy diet food
low carb diet healthy meal plans and
diet plan weight loss so if I go in to
Google's Keyword Planner and type those
keywords in I'm going to choose get
results and now here I could see healthy
diet plan keyword I'm focusing on is my
primary keyword has an average monthly
search volume of 9900 and then some of
my secondary keywords healthy diet foods
diet plan weight loss low carb diet you
know Google will give me a number of
different keywords to work with so I'm
going to look at the search volume of
those as well and so ideally what I want
to do is be able to then look at the
volume and then look at the competition
so healthy diet plan to go into my
keyword analysis here that's my theme so
that's my keyword what's my volume for
healthy diet plan nine thousand nine
hundred what's my competition so my
competition is seventy four thousand
seven hundred and that's going to give
me a ratio of volume to competition of
13 so that's what my content's about
that's a considered a short tail keyword
because it has a lot of competition and
so my ratio is 13 and what I want to do
is I want to be able to put these other
secondary keywords in here as well maybe
even go to a little longer tail because
I want to be able to find two key
release two keywords I want to be able
to find my primary keyword that's
relevant to my content and then I want
to be able to find my secondary keyword
which is again related to the primary
keyword which is also related to the
content and so I want to be able to
choose two keywords basically and I want
to choose two keywords that are relevant
that have good ratio between volume and
competition so that's the whole idea
again I'm how to do keyword research you
want to be able to find your keywords
use the tools available to you and get a
sense of what the volume is what the
competition is look at the ratio between
the volume and competition and then
based on the content choose that primary
keyword and then again based on the
keyword you chose choose some secondary
keywords as well because you want to be
found for not just one keyword but
multiple keywords okay let's look at
some alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account LSI
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like quora or Reddit we can use
Google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
Wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like Reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
LSI keywords and LSI stands for latent
semantic insect indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that are linked to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keyword
words you always want to choose that
primary keyword and then secondary
keywords that are similar to the primary
keyword and usually those are LSI or
latent semantic indexing type keywords
so they're used to drive relevant
traffic to your page so if you focus in
on one keyword we want to have other
keywords that are similar to increase
our visibility on the search engine
result pages so we could find latent
semantic indexing right in search so if
we use the term healthy diet if we go to
Google search for example if I type in
healthy diet and Google search all I
need to do is scroll to the bottom of
the page and I can see searches related
to healthy diet so healthy diet menu
healthy diet essay what does a healthy
diet look like notice at the top
Google's also given me some other
suggestions here so they're saying
low-fat diet veganism gluten-free diet
so there's lots of different suggestions
right in Google search bar are so all of
these are LSI related keywords so if
you're optimizing a page for a healthy
diet then you could choose low-fat diet
as a secondary keyword you can use
gluten-free diet as a secondary keyword
it really depends on what the content is
but you always want to support your
content with as much LSI keywords as
possible so you can be found for as many
different keywords as possible in Google
search so it's important because if you
have a Blog that you know talks about
python so how do the search engines know
if the website python is about the
programming language or the snake so
Google for example uses LSI keywords to
understand what the page is specifically
focusing on so if you're just focusing
on Python and your content you want to
support that with LSI keywords and so
that will allow your web page to better
communicate with Google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and and featured Snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you could certainly
be found for feature snippet for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if I
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if I'm talking about
recipes that's a key word I may want to
use and if I use that then Google has an
opportunity to see what my content's
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of the
questions are being asked what males are
good for weight loss what is a good
healthy diet plan all of these can be
keyword phrases that you can use so the
answers are right here in Google so core
is a great platform because core is a
platform that people go and ask
questions in a community response with
answers or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about core is it's a good eye it's a
good place for you to go to get some
ideas about a specific topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find keywords with high search volume
writing core so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant
keywords to healthy dieting so if you
just type in that particular keyword in
quora you're gonna probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if I
just type in healthy dieting what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna get some
responses to the the topic healthy
dieting so what's the best diet for
Healthy Living what are the top five
tips for a healthy diet habit so all of
these could be keyword phrases that you
could take away with for your own
content and so the benefit here is
you're getting kind of an idea of what's
trending what people are talking about
and if you use tips for a healthy diet
habit for example and you optimize for
that well well again I could turn around
and bode well for you because you could
be featured in Google as a featured
snippet at the top here you can also
turn around and use LSI related keywords
for healthy diet habits and you can
simply just look for those LSI keywords
right in Google remember at the bottom
or at the Top If you scroll down I could
see some related LSI keywords at the
bottom so writing Google as well you
could see in the Google search bar that
Google provides some LSI related
keywords to your query so if I go back
here and type in healthy diet recipes I
can see here Google's suggesting some
other related keywords healthy diet menu
healthy diet for man healthy diet foods
healthy diet for women so these are all
LSI related keywords that you can use to
support your primary keyword and the
content you're writing about so we've
talked about LSI keywords where to find
them so they're found right here they
can be found at the top of Google and
they can be found at the bottom you can
also then go to core as well and get
some ideas for the types of questions
that are being asked so if you ask a
question and use that as your keyword
phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in Google just by doing some
additional research within Google itself
or on quora so according to Google the
autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by Google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for terms so Google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if I go back to
Google again if I start to type in
recipes I could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most popular queries
related to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet Google's going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in Google itself I could see for healthy
diet recipes billions of pages related
to healthy diet recipes I can also get
the search volume by going into Google's
Keyword Planner so if I type in healthy
diet I'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition I can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that Google is going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if I'm looking for healthy diet
Google's going to suggest hey maybe you
should choose healthy food or healthy
eating or how to lose weight so those
are LSI related keywords that Google
provides in the keyword plan which is
built into the Google ads platform
another option for you is Wikipedia so
Wikipedia is a vast platform of content
so we could turn Wikipedia into our own
assets and use it to our own Advantage
by finding relevant keywords in an easy
fashion so with Wikipedia we can
identify a list of keywords in The Meta
description itself we could choose
keywords from the paragraph of Wikipedia
that has many relevant keywords or we
could take a look at keywords from the
Wikipedia content section so we can also
see additional Pages like the see also
section that gives relevant keywords
that you're looking for we can also look
at the references section as they
contain relevant keywords so go to
Wikipedia as an example and I type in
healthy diet into Wikipedia here I can
get just in the first paragraph alone I
can see some additional keywords that I
might choose to use like micronutrients
I never knew that micronutrients was
related to healthy diet but Wikipedia is
providing some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe I can use
that as a keyword an LSI related keyword
to my content so if I scroll down I get
to see also section so it might give me
some information food information
consumers for example dietary guidelines
I can look at categories like dietetics
and diets I can also look at the
references section so I can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
I can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to my main
keyword healthy diet so the answers are
right in here on the platform they're
just all over the page so Wikipedia has
an abundance of information you just
need to know where to look so again with
Wikipedia you can look no further in the
first paragraph you look no further than
the see also section the references
section category section there's lots of
information right on the page itself to
help you get ideas for keywords so if
you Google your keyword with Wikipedia
term in the search query and get
relevant keywords from the title tags
and the syrup so you can also do that as
well so if I type in healthy diet
Wikipedia and search I can also get some
information here as well so people also
search for healthy food advantages or
healthy food habits essay or information
about healthy food all of these are
related to my keyword healthy diet so
again another bit of information for you
to choose or look to choose some
additional keywords for so Reddit it's a
popular Community where people post
content and discuss a variety of topics
so that's what Reddit is so with the
help of subreddits an individual can
find relevant keywords with with high
search volume so in Reddit there's an
easy way to find out keywords they have
a keyword tool called keyword it so the
keyword it gives the average monthly
searches for a particular keyword so if
we type a Word in key Reddit and choose
keywords from the auto generator list
this tool will extract the keywords and
give us those relevant terms with search
volumes so if we go to the keyword it
and Show an example of that for example
healthy food if I get keywords I can see
what keywords are relevant in the search
volume of that keyword so if I just type
in healthy food keyword tool is going to
tell me some relevant keywords and what
the volume is so if you don't have the
Keyword Planner tool and Google ads
available to you this is a good
alternative solution to finding keywords
so it's free you just need to go to
keyword.com type in your keyword click
get keywords and what it's going to do
is give you some relevant keywords
related to your primary keyword with the
search volume let's talk about keyword
clustering now so the whole idea about
keyword clustering is to really take
advantage of the keywords that we're
optimizing for to gain higher ranking so
if we can cluster keywords together in a
theme and that theme of keywords is
relevant to a specific page of website
and we have a better opportunity to rank
so in other words why do we have to
Target just one keyword when we can
Target many so keep in mind you know LSI
keywords we want to group a bunch of
keywords together that are similar for
Content so for example after some
keyword research you can thematically
group keywords into a core topic so for
example we can cluster these group of
keywords together like for example what
is SEO how does SEO work intro to SEO
what are the basics of SEO all of those
are related to the chord theme what is
SEO another cluster of keywords for
example could be SEO techniques SEO best
practices tips and tricks website
optimization on-page SEO techniques Etc
so those are clusters of keywords okay
that we can group together in themes and
if we group keywords together in themes
we can apply that to a particular
content on our website so the whole idea
behind clustering keywords it's going to
provide more diversity more of an
opportunity for us to be found so that's
the whole idea behind clustering so some
additional steps remember stay up to
date on industry news to brainstorm your
ideas first and identify a list of
keywords like a thema keywords that you
can cluster together and then you could
determine the keywords that your
competitors are already ranking for so
for example if we want to rank for the
keyword SEO best practices for example
we can use a tool called keyword Moz if
I go to keyword the keyword Explorer
tool and Moz and just type in SEO best
practices what it's going to do is it's
going to give me some volume related to
that particular keyword but more
importantly what it's also going to do
is it's going to show me what pages are
already ranked for that particular
keyword so therefore I can get a sense
of who is already ranking for that
keyword word so here I can see Moz Moz
medium.com alexa.com so I can get a
sense of what web pages are ranked for a
particular keyword or group of keywords
I want to rank for myself so if we look
at tools for keyword research look no
further than Moz that's the mods of the
tool I would just choose but you could
also use Google's Keyword Planner which
we used in the example so for example if
I go back to the Google ads Keyword
Planner if you're in Google ads you
click on tools you click on Cleveland
planner and what Keyword Planner does is
it provides you for a particular keyword
the average monthly search volume of the
past 12 months it provides you
information on seasonality so if I hover
my mouse over a graph I'm going to be
able to see the volume per month over
the last 12 months what the keyboard
planner also does is it provides me some
additional ideas for my particular
keyword and in addition to that it's
going to provide me some sense of how
how competitive that keyword is by
telling me whether it's low medium or
high in terms of competition so there's
sem Raj there's also other additional
keywords tools out there like word
stream or href or the Reddit tool
keyword it and then Moz is is another
tool I particularly use so if I go to
Moz again here I can just type in a
keyword that I'm interested in it's
going to give me the search volume of
that keyword it's going to give me the
level of difficulty so 50 out of 100 so
it's halfway between difficulty and easy
and then it's going to give me some
additional metrics like for example what
my expected organic click-through rate
would be if I were to rank for this
keyword but more importantly what I like
about this is we could see exactly what
other sites are linked to this
particular keyword we're interested in
so here I can look at the top 10 list so
this is moz's keyword Explorer tool so
that's what this tool is and it's part
of moz.com so there's a lot of tools at
your disposal I particularly use Moz I
particularly use Google's Keyword
Planner and those are the tools I use
but there are lots of tools out there
Google analytics I'm very excited to be
with you today because Google analytics
is one of my favorite Google platforms
and my favorite topics so let's talk
about what we're going to cover today
and we're going to start out with how to
set up a Google analytics account and so
we're going to talk about everything
that entails including creating your
Google analytics account we're going to
talk about setting up a property in your
account and what a property is we're
going to talk about setting up a
reporting view in your property and
we're going to talk about installing the
tracking code so those are the series of
steps we're going to go through today in
terms of setting up a Google analytics
account so let's get right to it and so
really the Bruin prerequisite here when
it comes to setting up a Google
analytics account is to have a Google
login and ID so when you actually go to
Google analytics you need to be able to
sign up or sign in and so once you
actually sign in then you're gonna go
walk through a series of steps but
really that's really all you need to get
the account going is a Google ID and
login so if you have a Gmail account or
an other email account that you use for
other Google products then you're good
to go that's all you need to do so when
you actually go to sign up for Google
analytics you're going to be asked to
set up a new account and these are the
series of steps you're going to walk
through or go through to set up a new
Google Analytics account so you're going
to choose an account name and then
you're going to choose a property name
okay so the account name can be anything
you want it to be to name your company
your name whatever you want to name it
the property name is real really the
website name so what website are we
talking about so here I'm going to set
up a fictitious website name for now
it's called demo simply learn so the URL
for this website demo simply learn is
going to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
in analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and I'm going to talk about why
that's important here in a minute and
then you're going to choose your time
zone and the time zone is also important
because that's when the day starts in
analytics and the day ends based on that
time zone so the data that Google
analytics collects starts and ends with
that time zone so very important to
choose the time zone your business is
located in okay and then you have some
additional options here okay so you have
some settings and so the first setting
is to allow Google products and services
so if you opt into this then basically
what Google's going to do is share some
products and services with you via email
I would go ahead and opt into that
that's of course recommended by Google
it doesn't hurt to hear from Google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so benchmarking to me is
something you should opt into so going
back to that industry and category we
chose jobs and education so by opting
into benchmarking basically what
Google's going to do is share your data
that it collects on your website in this
case
demo.simplylearn.com it's going to share
that data anonymous anonymously with
others in the industry in this case jobs
and education and because you've opted
in it's going to do the same exact thing
for you it's going to share Anonymous
data on other websites in the same
industry and the benefit of that is we
get to see what other websites or how
other websites are performing compared
to ours what's the Benchmark in our
industry and so the benchmarking to me
is important and I'm gonna go over that
in a few minutes when we go over the
different reports but to me I would
always opt into benchmarking because
this is the only report Google provides
in analytics about how others in your
industry is performing versus your
website okay so it's a way to compare
your website performance against others
in the same industry the other options
here technical support and account
specialist I would also recommend you
opt into those because then it allows
you to basically Google allow Google
access to your account and they'll be
able to help you if you occur or run
into any issues so these are the options
in setting up a Google analytics account
it's very simple very easy to do you're
just entering in a few Fields note that
we talking about a website right now so
I'm talking about
demo.simplylearn.com but just know that
if you want to track a mobile app Google
analytics will allow you to do that as
well you just choose the option mobile
app so we're tracking a website we want
to know how users behave when they get
to my website and that's what Google
analytics is going to allow us to
measure and look at we just need to do a
couple more steps in the process so once
we fill out these fields here we're
going to click get tracking ID now I'm
going to accept the terms of service I'm
going to accept another terms and
service in relation to data protection
I'm going to click accept once I accept
I'm I'm going to be able to get some
tracking code the tracking ID is the ID
associated with your account and so this
number is going to be associated with
your account so your account ID starts
with UA and it's going to be this number
here now the dash one is the property
you set up so in this case I set up
demo.simplylearn.com if I wanted to
track multiple websites under that same
account then I can certainly set up
multiple properties just know that every
property I set up in that account is
going to have a dash 1-2-3-4
Etc depending on how many properties I
set up so by default I set up one
property so my first property ID is dash
one if I set up a second property the
same account number it's just gonna have
a dash too and that's important because
that ID that account and property ID is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking ID up here notice
the tracking ID in the snippet code now
this snippet of code needs to go on
every page of your website that you want
to track and you don't have to put it on
every page but if you want to track
website behavior on every page or
website then it needs to go on every
page of your website so if you're using
a you know platform like Drupal or
Joomla or even more popular platform
like WordPress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
Google analytics plugin to Wordpress for
example and then just simply plug in in
the ID now there's is an alternative to
adding the Google analytics tracking
code to your site and that's Google tag
manager so Google tag manager is the way
I would recommend going so if you're not
familiar with Google tag manager I would
recommend watching the YouTube video we
have on Google tag manager you can just
go to YouTube Type in simply learn
Google tag manager and this will give
you a nice overview of you know what
Google tag manager is and how it works
but basically this is the way I would go
and I would recommend that in addition
having Google analytics you set up a
Google tag manager account and then that
way you can put the tracking code in
Google tag manager so if I go to Google
tag manager and I just go into an
account on tag manager I can just simply
put in the Google analytics ID right
into tag manager and so if I have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
fires page view when somebody comes to
my website so that way I don't have to
add the tracking code to my website if I
do it in tag manager so that's the
recommended method for me is to add the
Google analytics ID associate it with
tag manager if you can associate it with
tag manager then that's the easier route
to go versus putting code on your
website okay so again take a look at the
video we have on YouTube for Google tag
manager that's the route I would go now
once you do get the tracking code on
your website whether that be through
Google tag manager or through a Plugin
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site then what's going to happen is
you're going to start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code to your website now if
you're not ready to do that and you
simply want to to basically understand
how Google analytics works then I would
recommend getting access to Google
analytics demo account and so if you
just type in and search Google analytics
demo account basically what you're going
to do you're going to choose the first
listing there and you're going to go to
demo account so if you have a Google
analytics or Google login then all you
need to do is click on access demo
account and so what Google is going to
do is put this demo account into your
account
and so it's going to look something like
this so if I click on demo account here
it's going to add to my Google analytics
account so I'm going to have then access
to the demo account from Google and
Google analytics so I would recommend
going this route here if you're not
familiar you're not sure what you're
getting yourself into so think of the
demo account as kind of a test drive
you're test driving Google analytics
before you even add any code to your
website so again all you need is a
Google account and if you have a Google
account and you add the demo account to
your Google analytics account you're
going to be able to see how analytics
works okay and so that's what I would
also recommend so if you're not ready to
start adding code to your website then
what you can do is just simply add the
demo account and then once you add the
demo account you're free to peruse
around Google analytics to see the
different types reports it has to offer
now when you do actually set up a Google
analytics account you're going to have
some settings that you're going to want
to pay attention to so when you set up
the account you have the account name
and then you have a property so under
each property you have by default you're
going to have one View and so here you
can see this view here so if we look at
the account we set up we set up a demo
simply learn account property is demos
simply learned so that's associated with
the website we're going to track and
then again by default under each
property you're going to have a view and
so by default the name of the view is
going to be called all website data and
so in that view is where all your
analytics data is going to be stored so
you can see my screen here there's a lot
of different settings you have you have
settings under the account you have
settings under the property and you have
settings under the view so we're going
to talk more about these settings and
future webinars for advanced Google
analytics users but for now know that
there's a bunch of settings that you
have that you can play around with when
it comes to Google analytics anything
from adding users to your Google
analytics account your Google analytics
property or view you can actually set up
goals you can set up filters you can set
up segments you can link up Google ads
you can you know set up remarketing list
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to Google
analytics but so know those settings are
there they're located right down here in
this little sprocket icon that's the
admin icon so if you need to get to
these settings at any time you could
simply just click on the sprocket or the
admin icon and then you'll be prompted
to choose any one of these settings here
that you want to edit or alter so now
let's take a look at some Google
analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number number of different reports that
you have available to you in Google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in Google
analytics so if I'm an admin and I'm
looking at the Google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
I click on the real time report and I
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users I actually
have active on the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here I can see that 79 percent
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent are coming
from tablet here I can see how they
actually came to the website so this is
the referring Source if they came from
say search or social I can see the
source there and I can see what pages
they're active on and then here I could
see what locations where they're located
and so if I want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview I can
certainly do that if I go to locations
under real time I could see a majority
of my users are coming from the United
States okay where are they coming from
I'll just click on traffic sources and
here I could see the different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven so if it's Google
it's either paid search or organic
search so I can see here it's organic
then I can actually see what contents
they're looking at on my website so I
could see currently I have three active
users on the home page two active users
on the Google's women's white t page so
forth and so on now most importantly if
you have a vent tracking set up so if
you're taking a look at our Google tag
manager webinar you know that you could
set up event tracking in Google
analytics to measure engagement on your
website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if I click on
events I'll be able to see what events
are firing so here I can see we have
event tracking set up and I can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here I can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and I could see that
that these are the current events that I
have currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if I
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes I could
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now I could see I had one active user
who entered the checkout so that's goal
number four so in analytics you can have
up to 20 goals and so here I can see we
have goal number four has already had
one active user and so if I look at the
last 30 minutes I can see I still have
only one goal over the last 30 minutes
and that was somebody who entered the
checkout so that's real time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's currently happening in on your
website and so for me ideally if I'm
launching a campaign or let's just say
you do a new website redesign and you
want to see how users performing and
behaving then real time is a good option
for you so you can see how things are
happening in real time now let's jump
down to audience reporting so if I click
on audience this is just right
underneath real time I'm gonna see a
number of different reports available to
me under audience and so let's click on
the audience overview report so audience
reporting basically allows us to get a
sense of who is coming to our website
when I say who is coming to our website
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
specific person in fact Google doesn't
allow personally identifiable
information in Google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name uh social security number
credit card information
Etc however we could still paint a nice
picture on who is coming to our website
meaning what country city or state did
they come from what language what device
did they get to our website from how old
were they okay were they male or female
or other what interests do they have
what browser do they use so we can paint
a nice picture based on all this
information that Google analytics is
providing us under audience so if I go
to audience overview here I can see I
have all these different options
available to me to get a basic
understanding of who is coming to our
website so for example I could see a
majority of the people coming to our
website speak English and are from the
United States okay in fact that
represents 61 of the users and so Google
analytics does a great job of giving me
an overall percentage so if I have a 100
percent of the users I could see 61
percent of those users represented
English speaking users from the United
States seven percent represented English
speaking users from Great Britain and so
when it comes to analytics we have users
and users are broken down into two
categories they're either returning or
they're new so when you add the Google
analytics tracking script to your
website what's gonna happen is if a user
or when a user goes to your website
they're going to get cookied if it's the
first time they've been to your website
what Google analytics is going to do is
store a cookie in the browser so when
that same user comes back another day in
the same browser analytics is going to
recognize that that cookie is in the
browser and so then analytics is going
to categorize that user as a returning
user okay so that's how analytics is
able to differentiate new versus
returning so if that user doesn't have a
cookie in the browser then analytics is
going to recognize that store the cookie
and then count that user as a new user
and so when you're looking at analytics
you're going to be able to see a
breakdown of new versus returning so
here I can see over three quarters of my
traffic over the past week here I can
see April 6 through April 12th three
over three quarters are new users to the
website here I could see about 23 24
percent are returning users okay so I
can get a good breakdown of what type of
users are coming am I driving new
traffic am I driving traffic that's been
to my website before what language are
they speaking okay I can also paint a
bigger picture how old are they are they
what gender are they do they come from
mobile so let's take a look at some of
these different reports under audience
and so if I skip down now to
demographics I can click on overview and
when that report loads I can see now
under demograph Graphics overview I can
see the breakout of age ranges and so
here I can see the majority of the
traffic coming to my site again over the
past week now if I want to change this
date range I could simply do that I can
change the date range just by clicking
on the date range and then maybe going
say the last 30 days and I can even
compare it to the previous period or the
previous year I'm going to choose the
last 30 days I'm going to click apply
now I'm looking at data over the last 30
days and again you can change the date
range to any range you want you can only
go back as far as when you actually
created the Google analytics account you
can't go prior to that so here I'm
looking at the last 30 days and I can
see almost 47 of my users were in their
age range of 25 to 34. now when it comes
to gender I can see 66 percent represent
males so I can get a breakout of gender
and age as well as interest and click on
interest and look at the overview there
and see what the interest is of the
users who are coming to my site based on
in-market segments or Affinity I can
also choose language and location so if
I want to know exactly where my users
are located when they're coming to my
website I can click on location and here
I can get a breakout 43 of the users of
the last 30 days were from the United
States more importantly I can align my
audience with goals and we'll talk about
goals here in a minute but here I can
see if I have an e-commerce website I
can see of those 43 percent 0.29 of
those converted or purchased something
and that equates to 94 transactions so I
can get a good sense of not only how
many users are coming from a specific
kind country but are those users
converting if I click on mobile and
mobile to me is one of those reports I
tend to spend a bit of time on because I
want to know what devices users are
coming to my website and so for my
website here or this is the Google demo
website I can see mobile represents
approximately 27 of the traffic so
desktop still represents a majority of
the traffic so for you you want to keep
an eye on mobile because mobile is
definitely a majority of what people use
nowadays that's how people start their
day that's how they transact Via Mobile
whether that's purchasing something
communicating or searching it all starts
with mobile so you want to keep an eye
on mobile and more importantly you want
to keep an eye on Behavior so Google
analytics is telling me that yes I have
approximately 27 of my traffic of the
last 30 days days came from mobile how
are they interacting with my website so
if I look across this report I'm going
to be able to see different metrics so
if I'm measuring specific metrics
against my dimension in this case the
dimension is what we're measuring and in
this example we're measuring mobile I
can see that the bounce rate is
approximately 48 and bounce rate means
that if a user in this case for mobile
landed on a page they left the site
without going any further so they
consider it a bounce if they don't go to
another page if they leave the site from
the page they landed on and they don't
go any further that's considered a
bounce so bounce rate is the percentage
of people who come to the site and leave
the site without going any further so in
this case we have 48 bounce rate that's
almost half of our users should come
from mobile Lee leave the website from
the page they landed on so is that good
is that bad well it's open to
interpretation is definitely subjective
but you want to keep the bounce rate as
low as possible you want to keep people
on your site especially if you have an
e-commerce website you want people who
come to your website to purchase and so
here we can see 48 mobile and desktop
it's a little bit lower at 41 percent
now if I look a little bit further at
engagement I can see how many pages on
average do mobile users look at so
versus desktop it's a little bit lower
you can see 3.86 on desktop it's 4.5 now
if I look a little bit further in
engagement I want to be able to measure
how long somebody from mobile stays on
the website if they're bouncing at 48
but they're also looking at 3.8 Pages
3.9 almost 4 Page ages procession then
that means in this report analytics is
telling me they're spending about two
minutes on the site and interestingly
enough I can see that mobile over the
last 30 days had more transactions so 51
transactions versus 34 transactions from
desktop and interestingly enough the
e-commerce conversion rate is at 0.29
percent that's higher than desktop at
.07 it's lower than tablet but it's
higher than desktop and mobile has the
most transactions and since they have
the most transactions they have the most
Revenue at 2 380. so yes the engagement
isn't exactly as great as it is this
desktop but we can see that people are
still purchasing with their mobile
devices so it's something to keep an eye
on and mobile is something I definitely
look at in fact since it's such an
important report one
one thing you can do in analytics is if
you actually like a report and you think
you're going to look at that report
multiple times then you can simply just
go ahead and click save at the top here
so if I click save I'm going to enter a
name for this report I'm just going to
call it mobile report and click OK and
then what's going to happen is it's
going to be located under save reports
and save reports is located under
customization customization is located
above real time okay so if I close that
up you can see audience real time
customization if I click on
customization if I click on Save reports
I should be able to see my save report
here and I do so here I can see mobile
report if I click on it I can simply go
to the report I was looking at before I
saved it so save reports to me is a good
feature in analytics because it allows
you to quickly access a report that
you've saved in the past so just take a
look get one more report under audience
and let's go to benchmarking so remember
when we were setting up our analytics
account we had the option to opt into
benchmarking and I recommended you do so
and so if you did I actually opt into
benchmarking then you're going to be
able to see how your site compares to
others in the same industry so if I
click on benchmarking and then click on
channels what I'm actually able to do
now is compare my website with others in
the same industry so if I go back to say
jobs in education and I choose education
all education as my industry vertical I
should be able to see websites that are
in the same particular industry and how
I compare with those websites so I'm
choosing all countries I can narrow that
down if I wanted to I can just search
for the United States I can choose a
specific State and then I can choose use
a particular site size so here I'm
choosing sites by daily session so these
are sites that have an average of five
thousand to almost 10 000 sessions a day
and so in this vertical education in the
United States sites that have 5 000 to
9999 sessions per day that means that
they're approximately 310 web properties
contributing to this report okay based
on this criteria I chose now if my site
is similar meaning if I'm in the United
States if I'm in education and I'm
receiving five thousand to nine thousand
nine hundred ninety nine sessions per
day then I'm able to compare my site
against 310 other websites now Google's
sharing this data anonymously from the
other websites and they're doing the
same with your website to those
particular websites benchmarking reports
okay so it's a shared data anonymously
and in particular Industries and
verticals and so now I'm looking at a
channel report so if I want to see how I
compare to others in my industry then I
can go ahead and see my channel for
example in my driving as much traffic as
others in my industry and you can see
I'm not in fact I'm 76 77 percent worse
in terms of the amount of traffic being
driven from organic search so anything
in red is going to show as a negative
result a negative comparison whereas
something in green is a positive
comparison so if I look at engagement I
can see that I might not be driving as
much traffic but I can see that the
pages per session are better than the
side average or the industry average I
can see if I go over again looking just
at organic search I can see the bounce
rate is better than the industry average
so the channel report under benchmark
parking allows you to measure how you
compare to others in your industry and
you could do so by looking at location
and devices so if you opted into
benchmarking when you set up your
account then you'll be able to compare
your website against others in your
industry in your country region and
based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic was driven to your website so
how do these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see an
overview of how users whether they're
returning are new came to our website
and so what analytics does by default is
they have a number of default channels
and when we say channels we mean
analytics as grouping different channels
based on how users got to your website
meaning how did users get to our website
did they come via organic search meaning
did they type something into Google and
find you in the organic listing
analytics also groups users based on
whether they came to your site directly
meaning did they type in the URL
directly into the browser or did they
bookmark your website and come back via
the bookmark so they're grouping users
under direct they also group users under
referral meaning do they come from
another website they group users by
social do they come from a social media
platform like Twitter or Facebook if
you're running paid search meaning if
you're running paid search on say Google
then do they come from Paid search ads
now if you're running display ads on say
Google's Network Google's Display
Network that's a default channel so
analytics for group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default Google analytics groups users
and how they came to your website via
these default channels and so I could
see how many users came to the site from
each Channel now if I want to drill down
on this report I can click on all
traffic and then if I click on all
traffic I can go to channels I can look
specifically at the channels report it's
so now I can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users I can see
that number's about 56 percent so 56
percent of my traffic over the last 30
days came from organic search and so
those are the number of users again as a
metric you're also going to have
sessions and you'll see sessions a lot
as a metric so use are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so just like we looked at
with the audience reports when it came
to mobile we can also look at engagement
by channel so just like mobile we looked
at bounce rate pages per session average
session duration we can do the same
thing here with our Channel report more
importantly in addition to behavior we
can see conversions and since we're
running an e-commerce platform we could
see with the conversion rate is by
channel so organic search did drive the
most traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is 0.17
okay so how Google determines the
conversion rate they basically take the
number of transactions and divide that
by sessions so that means that over the
last 30 days organic search drove 38 123
sessions and of those 38 000 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to 0.17 which also equates to 3
000 in Revenue so I'm able to determine
not only how users are getting to my
website by looking at the channel report
I can actually see if they're engaging
and if they are converting and notice
when you look at a report in analytics
you can look at it by Channel you'll
also get a summary so here I can see a
summary or a total based on my date
range so I can see over over the last 30
days I've had 54 000 users 49
000 of them were new okay that meant
that out of those 54 000 users I had 70
000 sessions I could see my average
bounce rate was 43 the pages per session
were just over four and the average
session duration how long did somebody
stay on my website on average about two
minutes and 55 seconds the average
conversion rate was 0.14 and I had a
total of 97 transactions totaling 5500
okay and that's all over the last 30
days so any report you look at in
analytics is going to have a summary and
note that any report you look at in
analytics is going to allow you to save
it so if it's a report you think you're
gonna go back and look at at a future
date then you simply just have to click
on the save button conversely if you
don't want to save it you can simply
just export it so you can export it as a
PDF if I click on PDF it's going to
allow me to export that as a PDF now you
have other options available to you as
well you can do a Google sheet you can
export it as an Excel or you can export
it as a comma delimited file so here you
can see I can save it as a PDF if I want
to and if I click OK it's going to save
to my desktop or location of my choosing
and then I can go back and look at it in
that format at a later time so that's
the export feature available to you in
analytics again if you you could save it
as well or you can export it okay some
other reports under acquisition if
you're running Google ads note that you
can connect Google ads to analytics and
this is key because now I can see how
many people are coming from Google ads
to my website and are they converting
now this is important because with
Google ads I'm actually paying for the
click so you can see here I'm running a
report based on campaign data so I could
see what campaigns are driving traffic
how much a pain per click and you can
see on average I'm paying 34 cents per
click and then more importantly I want
to be able to see if they're converting
so you can see I've spent 810 dollars
over the last 30 days and received 858
dollars in Revenue so you want to make
sure that you link up your Google ads
account to your Google analytics account
for this very reason you want to be able
to see how your Google ads campaigns
perform once the users get to your
website and so I want to see if they're
engaging and I want to see if they're
converting so they're all sorts of
reports under Google ads so you can look
at it by keywords by search queries by
hour of the day if you're running
display campaigns you can look at
display targeting says all sorts of
reports under Google ads you just have
to link it up and you link it up under
the admin now there are other reports
that you can look at so if I go to
campaigns I can look at all campaigns so
if you're running all sorts of different
types of campaigns whether that be on
Facebook whether it be email whether
that be you know other types of
advertising let's just say Twitter or
Instagram you're going to be able to see
those campaigns here and that's under
all campaigns and again you'll be able
to see the campaign name and you'll be
able to see metrics associated with
those campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you're running e-commerce platform or if
you have goals set up so you'll be able
to look at how your campaigns are not
one not only driving traffic but two are
they converting let's go from
acquisition reporting to behavior so
Behavior reports are going to actually
show you how users behaved once they got
to your website once they landed on a
page on your website how did they behave
so when we looked at audience we got a
sense of who is coming with acquisition
we get a sense of how the traffic got to
our website did they come from organic
direct social Etc the behavior reports
allow us to actually measure how that
traffic behaved once they landed on a
page on our website and so if I go to
overview under Behavior now I'm looking
at this graph here it's showing me how
many pages I've had and a page view is
simply once a page is viewed it's
counted as a page view so if a user
comes to my site they're initiating a
session and if they look at a page then
that page is going to have a page view
okay so a user can look at a page
multiple times in a session and every
time they look at that page it's going
to count as a page view so here I can
see in this graph enough how many pages
I've had again over the last 30 days and
if I look further at my overview report
I can see the specific pages and how
many pages they've had and I can also
look at some other metrics okay the
average bounce rate the average time on
page I can look at the exit rate which
means how many people actually exited or
the percentage of people who exited from
that page so I can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if I click on site
content and I click on all pages then
I'm going to look at a report by Page
this is my Dimension this is what I'm
measuring my page and now I can see how
many page views each page had over the
last 30 days now note you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page use is equivalent to one per
session in other words if a user came to
my site and looked at the home page then
the home page is gonna have one you
unique page view and one page view now
if the user in that same session looks
at other Pages then every page that user
looks at it's going to have one unique
page view however if the user goes back
to another to the same page in the same
session then it's still going to be one
unique page for you but in this case the
home page if they look at the home page
a second time then the home page is
going to have two page views if they
look at the home page five times in one
session then the home page is gonna have
five total page views and one unique
page view okay so that's why unique
pages is equivalent to one per session
where pages is an accumulation of how
many times the page was viewed in the
same session so in other words you're
always going to have more page views
than unique pages okay so this gives me
a sense of how my pages performed so
again I can look at total page views and
then engagement so ideally what you want
to do with report like this is if a user
is not engaging on the page then that
should tell you something about the page
itself if they're not engaging if the
bounce rate's high if the time on page
is low if the exit percentage of exit
rate is high then you probably want to
do something with that page now these
are all pages but if I jump down to
landing pages my landing page report is
showing me how many people actually
landed on that page and so here I can
see under my landing page report I can
see the home page had 36 000 17 sessions
in the last 30 days that's how many
people landed on the home page so here I
can see 71 percent were news sessions
meaning that I had a lot of new users
who landed on the home page in fact 25
000 or 52 percent of the people who
landed on the home page for new I could
see the bounce rates about 42 percent
but are those who didn't bounce they
went on to look at about 4.5 pages per
session and spent about three minutes on
the site and the one thing I like about
the landing page report is I can also
see whether that particular page in this
case the home page did it help
contribute to a goal or conversion and
in this case I can see of those 36 000
sessions I had 22 transactions totaling
1200 in revenue and that's an e-commerce
conversion rate of 0.06 percent so the
home page over the last 30 days
contributed to 0.06 percent of the
revenue so this gives you an idea of
when somebody lands on your website and
they land on a page is that page helping
to move that person along meaning are
they not bouncing and is that page
helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under Behavior including site
speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed is
important because what Google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sampled
2835 page views and of that sample they
came back and said the average page load
time is about four seconds now ideally
you want to keep it as quick as possible
I would say even under three seconds
okay now there are other factors
involved with page load time the browser
you're using the country that you're
actually browsing that page from might
know how to have the best infrastructure
you may not even be on the best internet
Network meaning you're on a cell network
or the Wi-Fi is not that gray or you can
be on a page that just has a lot of
images or a lot of code that may slow it
down so there are other factors involved
and so what Google analytics does is
show you what those factors are so here
I can see by browser with the average
load time is if I want to look at
Country I could see what country is
contributing to the load time now the
great thing about the site speed report
is if I go to speed suggestions okay
what speed suggestions is going to do is
it's going to show me the page load Time
by Page and then it's actually going to
provide a link where I can actually
click on to get suggestions on
increasing the page load time so for
example I can look at this particular
page here this Google redesign shop by
brand slash YouTube page line number
five if I look at line number five I can
see the average load time of this page
is 8 seconds almost nine seconds okay
that's an eternity to some people now
notice this link next to it so Google's
recommending seven total suggestions so
if I click on seven total what it's
actually gonna do it's gonna open up a
new window and it's going to open up
another Google report called page speed
insights and Page speed insights is
going to give me some information about
what I can do to create correct correct
the page load of that particular page so
look at the site speed report it's
important because there is a correlation
between site speed or page load time and
user behavior of that page and there's
also correlation between page load time
and a page ranking organically on search
so page load time is very important it's
so important that I'm even going to save
it so I'm going to click save and click
on speed site speed suggestions as my
name and click OK and now that report is
going to be saved under customization
under save reports let's jump from
Behavior to conversions now conversion
reporting is arguably the most important
section in in Google analytics because
what the conversions reporting allows us
to do is see how people are converting
or if they're not converting on our
website and so in Google analytics we
have the opportunity to set up goals now
you have the opportunity to set up 20
goals in your Google analytics View and
so to set up a goal okay so you're going
to click on admin and Under The View
you're going to see goals and so if you
don't even have goals the first step is
to create goals and so you have four
different goal types in analytics so you
have pages per session so how many pages
per session is so if your goal is set to
say three or two if somebody actually
looked at two or if three pages per
session it's going to count as a goal
okay so if I look here I can see I have
pages per session set at 10. so that
means that if a user came to the site
looked at more than 10 pages per session
then it's going to count as a goal
another goal type is destination so
destination means that if somebody
actually went to a specific page then
it's going to count as a goal and in
this case I can see here that the goal
is set to this particular page here and
so when somebody actually lands on that
page it's going to count as a goal now
there are two other goal ties we can
look at one is duration so just like
pages per session in our previous
example is somebody looked at 10 pages
per session it's going to count as a
goal with duration it's based on time so
in this particular case if you set up a
duration goal and the duration is set to
say one minute and 30 seconds ends then
that means if a user comes to my website
and they spend at least one minute and
30 seconds then it's going to count as a
goal okay and then the fourth type of
goal in Google analytics is an event
based goal so when you set up event
tracking you could turn that event into
a goal so if somebody clicks on say the
submit button of a form you can turn
that event into a goal so here you can
see the category equals contact form so
you can always verify if a goal works
just by clicking on verify this goal and
in this case this event is turned into a
goal so anytime somebody fires this
event it's going to count as a goal so
you have four different goal types in
Google analytics you have pages per
session destination event and duration
and so once you've set up a goal then
you can measure goals under conversions
so now if I look at goals overview I can
be able to see how many total goal
completions I've had so if I want to
look at it by goal I can just choose the
goal option here so if I want to look at
for example goal 2 engaged users this
was the pages per session I can see that
I had a conversion rate of 10 meaning
that I had 7 000 of all the users that
came to the website 7 000 gold
completions meaning
7106 users looked at 10 pages or more on
my website and so that's how you want to
be able to measure whether users
wherever they're coming from whoever
they are whatever Pages they look at you
want to be able to look at the
conversion reports to see if they're
actually converting based on the goals
you've set up whether that's pages per
session duration destination or event
goal conversion tracking reports can
help you measure who is actually
converting and the great thing about
Google analytics here is that I can
actually see by segments so the default
segment in a segment is just looking at
a specific user set so the default
segment is always all users however I
can choose a different segment so if I
want to choose instead of all users if I
want to choose Mobile Traffic I can
select Mobile Traffic hit apply so I'm
actually now looking at a subset of data
I'm looking at mobile traffic so if all
the mobile users have come to my site I
can see 1400 engaged or looked at 10
pages or more okay and that's a seven
percent conversion rate so the great
thing about Google analytics is you have
the opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rates of each
goal but you can also change the
segments of that particular goal to see
who exactly converted okay another
report I like under conversions is the
multi-channel funnel report so if I
click on multi-channel funnel basically
what this allows me to do is see how
different channels work together to
convert so remember the channel
reporting we looked at under acquisition
here I can see now how different
channels work together to drive the
conversion so if I look at three
channels direct organic and referral I
can see all three together drive two
percent of the conversions if I look at
direct and referral twelve and a half
percent if I look at direct and organic
12.24 so I can see how different
channels work together and so if I look
at top conversion paths as an example I
can actually see what channels how
channels work together to drive the
conversion so in this example I can see
over the last 30 days that my top
channel group open was direct times 2
meaning that somebody came to the
website directly meaning they typed in
the URL in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination is my top conversion
combination of the last 30 days my
second best conversion grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral or referring website and
converted then the referring website's
gonna get the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so so a channel may drive a lot of
traffic like organic search but that
traffic may not convert the first time
around for a number of different reasons
whether it could be brand recognition
Price shopping reading content whatever
the case analytics is able to measure if
that channel actually did contribute at
a later point and in this case we could
see organic search drove traffic that
didn't convert but that traffic came
back a second time via direct and did
convert so that's our second best
Channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling Report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only have channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns from different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition Behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance now if you have any comments
or questions about any of the reports we
covered feel free to comment underneath
this video we're definitely going to
have more webinars in the future about
specific analytics settings that we
didn't get to today and other types of
analytics reports and features that we
didn't get to today the concept of
linking is foundational to good rankings
and understanding the internet at Large
it starts with the premise that good
content will be cited by others
recommending it to other people
how we cite and recommend information
online is by linking to it
we link to information that we find
valuable
based on that the search engines assess
content by how websites link to one
another
so we are going to cover the definition
and purpose of links and the different
functions that links serve
we'll also look at how Lynx mirror human
judgment
we'll look at how search engines
evaluate links by mirroring human
judgment
and how that affects what's called Block
Level analysis
and how where the location of different
links and how they are used will greatly
affect their relevance
we're going to look at how visitors from
different link sources will behave
differently based on where they came
from
and also how you can measure the
effectiveness of links and finally we're
going to look at both good and bad
linking practices now links serve a
number of purposes
from a functional standpoint they
usually are our primary means of
navigation online we click on links we
go to different pages and from those
pages we find links to other pages
links are also a method of citing other
content
when we quote somebody when we use
information that we have found somewhere
else we cite that information to give
credit to the original author
typically online we do that with a link
so that if someone wants to see the
original Source document it's available
to them that also helps to provide
credibility to you
credibility to the author of the
original source as well as assigning
importance to the knowledge that came
from that original source and the
authority of the original source
links also provide us with a clear
structure of how our websites are built
how the pages relate to one another and
how organized the information can be
so let's break down the functional part
of a link
this is important if you're going to be
developing anchor text and linking to
understand the structure
the ahref equals is the start of the
link tag
what you are doing is developing the
reference of where the document is
contained that's the href reference is
what it is short for
what comes next within the quotes is the
location of the document now this can be
a full URL or you may just be linking to
a document that's on the main root level
of your server
this is the full location where you can
access the document
and so you're putting the name of the
document the extension so that it will
be linked
the next part is what I have in caps
you'll notice off to the left I have
something in all blue text and
underlined which most people will
recognize as a link
you see when it is in between the
document location
and the closing of the link tag the text
you have in there is what's called
anchor text
you see instead of publishing the
document location and the full URL of
the document
we can put the link within text and
create anchor text so all someone has to
do is click on the link and the document
loads for them
this anchor text is vitally important to
understanding how we can add additional
relevance to linking content
then we see the closure of the link tag
this is what makes the internet the
internet is millions of pages connected
together by Links
so when we look at the functional side
of links and we look at this example
here as you can see the title of this
article is not the URL address of the
article it's a title and the title is
the link that is the anchor text of the
link
and so from a search engine standpoint
search engines look to see what words
are being used in the link and how
relevant those words are to the document
that is being linked
it also looks to see where is the link
is it in the editorial information in
the article
is it part of the navigation
is it in a sidebar or is it an ad
and then also search engines are looking
to see if this is a text link or an
image link
how long has that link been there
what type of link is it does it go
somewhere within your website does it go
to another website or is it a reciprocal
link which I will explain more later
they also look to see the text in the
link and the context to the page with
the link directs you to
we utilize links a little differently
you see from a human standpoint whenever
we refer information to another person
when we provide reference material to
another person or even if someone asks
us for a recommendation we provide this
information
you see offline we mirror the same
behavior as we do online when we link
people ask us for information and we
provide it
we just mirror that online by making a
link
offline we recommend we refer we provide
information to each other in much the
same way the way I want you to think
about it from a human standpoint is that
if you asked another person for advice
or directions or a referral
are there certain people that you would
trust more than others
I'm sure the answer to that is yes and
maybe you have some people in mind that
you are thinking about
you see we run across the same issue
with search
the search engines know that there are
some websites that are much more
trustworthy than others
just like if you were to ask someone for
information I'm sure you would ask the
right person
for the information you would ask the
most knowledgeable trustworthy person
you knew
who had Authority in that subject area
the search engines are trying to do the
same thing with the links that we
publish on our websites they're trying
to determine who is the most trustworthy
and relevant based on the
recommendations referrals and citations
of other websites to other websites
who are the websites that are trusted
that are authorities
the search engines are trying to do from
a technical algorithmic standpoint what
we do naturally from a human standpoint
now from The Human Side as I had said
before we need to think of links as
information that we receive from other
people
Word of Mouth advice information
directions recommendations this is where
we need to think about links not from
the standpoint of building false
relevance for a search engine but being
a helpful resource for our readers how
can we help them how can we provide
information and how can we be a credible
source of information
how can we develop our Authority within
the industry and so that people who have
questions about this content will see
our websites as authoritative and
credible resources
the best way to develop links as you'll
see is good content when people like
what they read when they like what they
see when they are willing to recommend
it to others it's because you have
created something of value
and they'll link to you when they feel
that you are credible
and that you are authoritative with this
information
only then will they share it with other
people
because you have earned that right for
them to share it with others by
providing content that is informative
educational
entertaining and you've provided that
service
only then will people then want to
recommend it to others by linking to it
now links serve a number of benefits
When I look at some of the incoming
links to my site one of the things I
notice is that if I get a link in
certain places that can drive a lot of
brand exposure I can have thousands of
people coming to the site looking to see
an article and that provides a lot of
exposure to a lot of people
however also getting a link from a
certain website especially if it's a
high relevant authoritative website I
can see my rankings increase because of
that
but then also a good link is going to
drive people that will convert and drive
sales or leads those who become
customers
so those are the three aspects of a good
link a good link will drive traffic to
your site a good link will assist your
rankings
and a good link will bring in business
if you can get a link to do all three of
those at the same time that's what I
call the golden link because it has all
three benefits
usually however you're going to find
that different links will provide
different types of benefits one of these
three or maybe two out of these three
one of the things I'm usually very
focused on is the link that drives sales
or generates leads that's getting links
in the right place that will benefit me
tangibly rather than just getting
thousands of people to see it
why it benefits me financially if I can
get a link in the right place
so from here let's break down the
different types of links we have
navigational links we see these in our
navigation our primary navigation maybe
the footer of our web pages where we
have links to typical information such
as about us or contact us
we also have sidebar links this might be
related information or offers or calls
to action
and then also I would break it down into
outbound or inbound type of navigation
outbound are links going to other
websites inbound links are links that
come from other websites and that also I
might send to other pages on my own site
now I've used the term editorial an
editorial link is a link that is found
within the content of the website
and by that I mean through an article
so if I am writing an article and I link
to someone else and cite them or
reference them
that is what's called an editorial link
it means that it's part of the content
a great example of this is that the
navigation on your web pages is not part
of the content
it serves a function as navigation
but it doesn't have anything to do with
supporting information with citing and
Authority
so information and links that you put
within the content and presented content
of your site are considered editorial
now there's also a call to action links
where you're bringing someone to a
landing page or a registration page or a
sale page
then also we have Social Links now these
can provide a variety of means but
typically a social link will go to a
profile
maybe it's a username that takes you
somewhere else or comment or maybe just
an image or something that goes to a
social site or that you have placed on
your own site as well
either way it's all contained within
that social network even though the
links are going on and off your site
they tend to be controlled in that
social environment
now I've used the term reciprocal link
now this is
something very specific
a reciprocal link is one where you would
go to somebody else and you would make a
trade such as if you link to me I'll
link to you and maybe you put those
links on the home page or maybe you
create a page just for that link
you see sometimes it just doesn't make
sense and so the search engines will see
that you've linked to each other but if
there's no contextual relevance if
there's no contextual relevance
most likely you won't get any benefit
because you've agreed to link to each
other for the primary purpose of
boosting rankings
now this is not to say that two websites
can't link to each other because there
is some relevance
we'll look at some examples of that
later on in this module
also then we have advertising links
these can be ads banners anything on the
page that is an advertising link that if
you were to click on it you would go to
that advertisers page
those links are typically through an ad
server and they take place in entirely
different ecosystem
but they are links and we need to know
what kind of links are advertising and
which kind of links are functional to
our websites
now when I broke down the different
types of links so we have our navigation
links we have links in our sidebar and
in our footer with Block Level analysis
does is that the search engines look at
the code of the page they break down the
page because it's very easy to figure
out which part of the code has to do
with your navigation which part of the
code has to do with your sidebar and
your footer and which part of the code
is calling ads from an ad server what
this leaves is the editorial content
your article and the ability of search
engines then to break down your page
into these different elements the reason
why they do it is that the links
contained in the editorial space are
considered to be more relevant in terms
of linking to other websites than any of
the other types of links on your web
page search engines don't consider all
parts of the page to be equally relevant
which is okay because neither do humans
we look at the navigation as utilization
pure utility because it's just helping
me navigate among the different pages of
your website I'm not expecting to learn
anything I'm using it as a functional
means of navigating your site the now
your sidebar might have some calls to
action it might have links to other
pages but it's not an article it's what
you've developed and so it might be a
little more important than your
navigation but it's not as important as
what you may have written within content
your footer navigation is basically the
same you control that it's the same on
every page and so what the search
engines are looking for are the unique
content
the unique article or information that
you've published and if there is a link
within the editorial content that is
highly relevant because it has to do
with content it has to do with
information that you are sharing and so
the links there are going to be more
highly relevant and are going to be more
important for the search engines to see
you see it's the same way with humans
we're not going to look at navigation to
learn something it's functional the same
thing with the footer and as humans
we're reading the content that you have
in your article and if you link to
another source well you've provided us
with utility but it's contextual utility
because you're citing where you found
information or you're citing an
additional Source or you are linking to
an example and it enables me as a human
to see that understand it and if I need
that additional information I can click
on it and go to it so I'm going to look
at the information on the page in that
article very differently that I'm going
to look at the headings the navigation
the sidebars or the footer because the
article is what is informing me and so
the links in the article I'm going to
look at very differently and hold them
in a higher level of relevance
now over time search engines have had to
refine the algorithm about links
you see in the early days of search
engine algorithms they used to Simply
count the amount of links than if one
site had more links than another that
made it more credible
however once people started to figure
that out people started accumulating
links by really any means necessary and
they were just looking for the sheer
volume of links because they knew if
they got the most amount of links it
would affect their rankings
and so over the years the search engines
have had to change and adjust and add
more relevance to their algorithm
refine it in order to look at different
aspects of links
in order to properly determine relevance
so over time it wasn't just having a
link it was then also looking at how
many people cite this site as an
authority so looking at the source of
the link and the types of pages
then also looking at the text of the
link and matching it with the text of
the page
does it match is it contextual
and then looking at the type of Link
doing the Block Level analysis
and then also the context the relevancy
of your site compared to the linking
site compared to the link and the
information that's being shared there
also some of the ways that they can look
at it at the age of the link how long
has that link been there
humans do the same thing when we look to
see how long someone has been in
business we're looking at credibility
and then of course there are many many
other ongoing refinements that are going
into the search engines evaluations of
links sometimes the age of the link
isn't as relevant especially when you're
looking for something that has happened
very recently
an Old Link could mean that it's old
news or that something has changed since
then
so search engines are in a constant
battle to ensure that people are not
gaming the system by falsely creating
relevance through linking
the link relevancy and the algorithm is
all about trying to determine who is the
most relevant and credible within this
area
and that is the focus of most search
engine algorithm refinements over the
past few years and it will be into the
future
now this is where I'm going to start
bringing in some screenshots from a link
Management program
as a search engine Optimizer a link
Management program is probably going to
be one of your best friends as you move
along in this industry
in this example this program link Decks
that I'm using will track the incoming
links to my website and it'll also
provide a breakdown as to what type of
website those links are coming from so I
can see how many links I have from blogs
how many links I have from news sites
how many links from wikis how many links
from directories forums social media
public relations sites articles or
additional resources
then I can also add my competitors and I
can compare where I stand in terms of
the amount of links from each source and
where my competitors stand
in this way I can be sure that we all
have a similar link profile you see if
my linking profile looks vastly
different than all my competitors the
search engines are going to see that as
well and know that something might be
different with me good or bad and that's
going to raise a red flag
so I want to look at the linking profile
because every industry and
almost every business is linking profile
is going to be a little different but
especially among Industries we see that
linking profiles that is the amount of
links from different sources it's going
to be slightly different for every
different type of industry or business
so this helps me understand where my
links are coming from which is vitally
important because from a business
standpoint one thing that I've tracked
consistently in analytics is that people
will act differently and also I can
predict which source is going to send me
the best customers
you see just because someone comes from
a link doesn't mean they're going to buy
or become a customer or really become a
lead
many times they're going to come look at
your information and leave
and based on how they come to your site
whether it's through a Blog a directory
a forum or a new site has a lot to do
with how they view your website
and it's all about
the context this is what I've learned
over the years is that people will
behave differently based on how they
find the website
what I found is that people from blogs
news sites and articles they tend to
stay longer do more and have a higher
chance of conversion of becoming a
customer or a lead
the main reason is because blogs and
articles they have a lot of context it's
an article someone has taken the time to
write some information out and then link
to my site which means there is a highly
contextual reason for someone to click
that link
also what it means is that there's a lot
less competition for that link when my
link is in that article
compare that with social news or any
type of social site
you see when you're on a social site and
you're looking at your social stream of
information there's a lot of different
people competing for your attention a
lot of different things and it's not
just in one subject area it's usually
from multiple subject areas and so the
context is very low because there's a
lot of different types of information
and the competition for your attention
is very high
because of that people from social sites
or applications
tend to visit more often but they only
tend to view one page and leave
immediately
because they're looking to see what was
interesting and then they move on to the
next subject
that's the difference between how people
react based on where they come from
and so when I'm measuring links I'm
looking to see which links do I have
what's the source and then how do those
sources behave differently from one
another
and why
you see if I find that I'm getting links
from sources that people are staying
longer doing more and converting at a
higher rate then I'm going to continue
to focus on building links in those
areas because it directly affects how I
monetize my website
so here's a strategy in building links
one of the things I'm looking at is the
source of links like I said if I can
find a link Source that's providing
visitors that will stay look at my
content engage with the content and
eventually convert and convert at a
higher rate than other sources of
content or visitors
then I'm going to focus on that source
and so I'm going to look at some high
Authority websites whether they're
industry Publications news sites
education sites those are what are
considered high Authority
blogs articles news sites
that's what I'm looking to do I want to
find the most authoritative website
and sometimes it happens naturally if
people that work at those websites or
manage those sites if they find you and
they like your content they'll link to
it and that way you can get more
credibility more relevancy
certain people certain organizations
certain websites have more Authority
influence than others it goes back to
the question that I asked you early in
this module that how do you know if
someone is more authoritative than
somebody else
we also have mid Authority websites
which you can get some links on and low
Authority websites which are very easy
to get links but here's what I've
learned when it comes to link building
one link from one high quality website
can be worth hundreds or thousands of
mid to low quality links
ultimately it's about quality not
quantity
one of the things that I will do
utilizing my link software is look at
the context of the link
I want to see how relevant this is so as
I said if I want to find a high relevant
website what I'm looking for in terms of
this is I want to see the influence of
the domain as well as the relevance of
the domain those are two factors that
we're going to look at when we're
evaluating the quality of a domain now
as I'm looking at this report here what
influence means is that it is a high
quality website that within the linking
algorithm these sites have a lot of
authority
however they may not be relevant
so for example they may have a lot of
sites attributing authority to them
but they may not be relevant to my
industry which is why we have the next
column of keyword relevance
you see when I'm evaluating my links I'm
looking for the sources that are both
influential and relevant
that means that I've got a link from a
site that fits the two standards of high
Authority it's authoritative and
relevant now it's good to have links
from authoritative sites that might not
be relevant it's still authoritative
however to get the full benefit I want
it to be influential and relevant but
not to say that I'm not looking for
links from these other sources this is
just a means of measuring what you have
as well as comparing it to your
competitors and other websites
now here's some best practices when I'm
optimizing anchor text I want to
maintain contextual relevance so I want
to use text in the text link and I want
to explain to people what they're
linking to what they're going to find
when they click on that link if I use an
image as a link I'm going to use an ALT
attribute because if that image doesn't
show up
that attribute
is necessary to let people know where to
go
but also I do get a little tiny bit of
benefit by using that alt attribute
within the image link
I also want to look at the relevance of
the source page that I'm linking to and
make sure contextually the link the link
text and the content of the page is
contextually relevant to the destination
page
I also want to be sure that I don't
overuse the keywords that I don't make
multiple links to the same destination
that I don't use the same anchor text
over and over
I can be downgraded or even penalized by
the search engine algorithm if that is
found on my pages
so as an example instead of using click
here
for a how-to article
I might use the exact phrase of how to
fix whatever it is and use that as the
link to the page that has the content
that's a simple way of looking at anchor
text am I directing someone to
additional information if I am then how
can I present it to them so they know
exactly what they're going to find and
Link it appropriately
I look at as developing the next step
for your readers where do you want them
to go what do you want them to do what
resources do you have available to them
how can you structure them so that
they're easily understood and you're
explaining the Final Destination
like I said if you overuse anchor text
you can be downgraded or penalized by
the search engines
so what I will tell you to do is number
one avoid overstuffing anchor content
that means needlessly repeating keywords
in the anchor text
don't do that
avoid being redundant meaning don't have
four or five or six links with the same
anchor text going to the same page
that's a clear way of letting search
engines know that you're going overboard
don't just randomly Place links
throughout your text just to get the
link
ask yourself are you really helping the
reader find the information they need
and do it once
and then also avoid extremely overly
promotional words within the linked text
such as best expert cheap number one
those types of things
so a couple examples we can say for
travel advice click here but I would say
here is my travel advice and Link travel
advice rewrite it be creative
if it were easy everyone would be doing
it
but this is where you can write things
in a better way to get the attention of
the reader and position it as a resource
also utilizing your url as the link or
as the anchor text as well for the link
in order to get that click
as I've got it here I would not
recommend that you use that I would
recommend that you avoid that
also the third line the check out the
best website for iPhones and iPhone
accessories utilizing overly promotional
words is one of those ways that you can
easily get caught by the search engines
now for future considerations when it
comes to Links realize that the majority
of algorithm changes are link based
evaluation refinements because people
are constantly attempting to fool the
search engines and develop a false link
profile
you should work to create high quality
links with high quality content
I wouldn't chase after Poor or low
quality links
now as I've mentioned before there are a
number of tools available for you to
manage and measure your backlinks tools
such as link decks Moz Raven Advanced
Link manager Majestic SEO and then also
you can use your Google analytics as
well however Google analytics only shows
you the visitors that have come from
links and what they've done the basic
functions of Link management software
and there are many other types other
than what are listed here but the first
thing that it does is just provide a
catalog of incoming links from other
domains to your site and your competitor
sites they offer tools for comparison to
see which domains are linking to you
what type of link it is and on which
Pages those links are listed they'll
also report newly acquired links in the
past 30 60 90 days or something similar
to that the purpose of Link management
software is to help you assess high
quality domains versus low quality
domains in terms of importance and
relevance
like I said the first job of a link
management tool is to collect all of
your backlinks you add your domain and
the tools will usually spider the domain
they'll go out into search engines and
go out into many other formats in order
to find and retrace who is linking to
you what page that link is contained
sometimes what text is on that page and
what text is being used in the link they
will catalog all of your incoming links
organize them format them and report
back to you most of these link programs
provide additional filters and
management tools so that you can get
more insights about who is linking to
you how they are linking to you and the
type of site
personally I use Link decks in order to
Monitor and report on my backlinking so
the first report here that I'm showing
out of linkedex is that I see the total
amount of incoming links to my domain
this says I have over 2 000 links and
those 2000 links are on about 1 000
domains on average it looks like I have
about two links from every domain that
is linking to me so this is one way that
you start to look at your links number
one the total amount of domains that are
linking to you and then the total amount
of links available this way you can
isolate domains that are linking to you
consistently and also find those that
may not be the best domains or that are
sending a lot of links that are just not
relevant
the next thing I do in analyzing My
Links is to look at the type of Link
meaning the type of site that it's
coming from
this report breaks down the amount of
links coming from blogs news sites
directories forums social sites articles
or resources now it doesn't usually get
all of those links but it does get
enough to give you an idea of how well
you're doing in each channel one of the
things that I do like about this report
is it also has a timeline so I can look
and see when new links have been
acquired and maybe when some links have
been just disappeared that's called
churn and it's normal it's normal
because many times a link is published
on social media and it kind of just goes
away or it's not tracked anymore by your
link management software it can't find
it anymore and so linking is always
Dynamic you are always gaining new links
and losing old links there's going to be
a normal amount of churn
the next report shows me all of the
domains that are linking to me it also
shows me in the next column how many of
those domains are also linking to at
least one competitor and it will list as
many competitors as I have listed in
here if they list to multiple
competitors
it would let me know the influence of
that site or the authority that site is
seen because of the amount of websites
and credibility that Authority has for
that domain it also let me know the
keyword relevance how relevant that
website is overall contextually to my
domain and the content that I have
it will also let me know how many pages
on that domain have links to my website
so I can also go through and I can
filter this list by the type of site I
can filter by those domains that are
using anchor text to see how much anchor
text is being used and what type of
anchor text there are many different
ways that you can filter through all of
the domains that are linking to you in
order to get an idea of what's happening
on your domain what are competitors
doing and also the relevance of those
links to your site
now when I say that I can add
competitors this is another type of
report very similar to the one I showed
earlier where I look at my own standing
in the different types of sources of
links such as blogs directories forums
and so on I can also when I add my
competitors look to see how they are
performing in those different areas as
well and so I can compare my link
profile to my competitors
different Industries are going to have
different backlink profiles they might
be more heavily weighted towards blogs
or they might be more heavily weighted
towards forums or social sites in this
way I can look to see if my competitors
are actively link building and how
they're going about it I can see where
maybe they are excelling in one area
that the rest of the competitors are not
so I can compare different strategies I
can also compare different timelines to
see if I am acquiring Links at a faster
rate than my competitors this is very
important if you are a newer business or
a newer website trying to compete
now specifically what I can do is look
at an individual domain in this case
this domain has three pages linking to
me and that domain also links to two of
my competitors I can look at the
specific pages and what I'm looking at
here are Snippets this should be
familiar to you because what it's
showing is the URL of the page that's
linking to my page it shows me the page
title of that page and then in this
report it lets me know if there are any
keywords being used in the link in the
anchor text as well as the number of
links from that page now what this tells
me is that this is most likely a
directory something that is listing all
the different places that where you can
buy products because it's most likely
the linking to the domain name seeing
that there are no keywords being used in
Anchor text and also that there are 16
out about links from that page that
means that it must be a list of some
sort and they are linking not only to me
but most likely to competitors as well
so I can track my Links at the Domain
level and at the page level I can look
to see which Pages might have more
influence or relevance to my content I
can also see the link URL the page title
if any keywords are being used in the
anchor text and also within the context
of how many additional links are leaving
from that page if there are a high
amount of outgoing links on that page
then a link from that page might not be
as valuable since there are so many
links the less links there are coming
out from that page the more it will
benefit my site because I'm getting more
benefit from less links
now also what I'm going to do is compare
the link reports to my analytics I'm
going to go to my analytics because
linking software does not show traffic
it doesn't show how many people are
clicking on the link it only shows who's
linking to you but it does not show
visitor activity analytics will show you
visitor activity to see which domains
are most effective in sending visitors
to your site if you go back to the
primary benefits of linking visitors
branding and business analytics show me
visitors and business it shows me which
domains are sending me visitors and
which of those visitors are becoming
customers
so what I can do is go to Google
analytics look at all the domains that
are referring traffic to my site I can
also click on the domain and see the
destination page that they are linking
to I can see how many visitors are
coming either monthly or annually how
often they're coming back whether
they're new users or repeat users how
long they stay how many pages they View
and how many conversions as a result of
those visits this is a great way to get
a 360 degree view of your linking
because not only do you want links that
will help you rank better you also want
links that will send business and
customers to you as well
building links can take many forms
ideally it is through networks
relationships and marketing that other
websites and users learn about you like
you and recommend you to others
unfortunately there is a lot of bad
outdated and untrustworthy advice to be
found about building links to your
website
in this section I'll present the best
practices as accepted by the omcp
standard
the objectives for this module that
you'll be able to develop a link
building strategy
that you'll understand the value of
different link types
finally you'll be able to find inbound
link opportunities
first step in building links is to
evaluate what you have
now there are many tools available that
you can utilize to do this for you there
are automated tools that you can get
that will catalog all of the incoming
links to your website
some of them are link decks Moz Raven or
Advanced Link manager there are many
that can do that you may also want to
utilize your analytics as well in order
to find websites that link to you
the first step is evaluating where you
are right now
your incoming links have a significant
impact on your rankings
and you can do a lot of on-page
optimization and see some results
however a lot of Google's algorithm
takes into account links from other high
quality websites
now when you evaluate what you have in
this example I'm showing you a
screenshot from link decks
link decks catalogs the incoming links
to my website and it groups them into
different areas
the first way it groups them is by high
value or high influence domains
those are websites that link to me that
have a lot of influence not necessarily
in my industry but High influence based
on the amount of people that link to
them as an authority on many different
subjects
the next way that it groups that is
based on relevance
now this is when it looks at the match
of my content versus the content of the
other website
in the first example we can see the
National Library of Medicine
it is a high influence website because
it is a government website with a lot of
information that is cited frequently
because of the amount of other websites
linking to that site it has a high
amount of influence
now based on the website that I am
measuring
there is a lot of keyword relevance
meaning that that National Library of
Medicine site with the government has a
lot of content that's very similar to my
site a lot of the same keywords are
being used
so not only is this website of high
influence it also has a lot of relevance
and that's key when evaluating my
backlinks
I want to look at which websites are
also referring traffic
so while I may have a link from the
National Library of Medicine I want to
look at my analytics and look to see is
it also providing visitors
our visitors following that link to my
site and I also want to look at the
quality of traffic that it produces
do these visitors stay longer than
average
do they convert more than average I want
to look at the quality of traffic based
on the source
next I want to look at the incoming
links from those other websites number
one I want to make sure that the
incoming link from the other site is
both accurate and relevant meaning the
text that is used in the link is it
accurate to the content that will appear
on the page when the visitor clicks that
link
is the content relevant this is
especially relevant if I have updated my
website changed the content or moved
things around
I want to be sure that that incoming
link sends visitors to the appropriate
page and the appropriate information
I also want to ensure that that link is
worded correctly that it uses the right
words that is sending visitors and
setting expectations of the content that
they will see
I may need to contact the website
manager or owner and maybe ask for a
better linked text or a more accurate
page destination
now this requires some interaction with
the owner or manager of another website
and you always want to be respectful of
their time and not demanding that they
make any changes
in some cases the organization may be so
big you may never find the right person
in order to optimize the text or the
destination of that link
you always want to look for accuracy in
cases where your company or website name
is utilized in the link
but also if there is any contact
information such as address phone number
a description of your business and any
content
make sure it's accurate and it all
points to the right place
another way to look for links is to
Simply go to a search engine and start
doing searches
search for your company your business
your company name and look for websites
that may mention you but do not have a
live link to your website
many times your company will be
mentioned or cited but there will not be
a live link you can only find these
through doing searches and seeing which
websites mention you without linking to
you
now this could be an opportunity to get
an Easy Link especially if you can find
some contact information and finding the
right person that could add a link to
your company information
again you'll need to be polite ask for
their help
and it will help it if you can develop
the link along with the link text and
send that over
giving them just a quick and easy edit
to be able to add the information
so make it as easy as possible
as an example I've provided a sample
request format
again you want to be polite you want to
be inviting and respectful of their time
and their management
sometimes like I said you may find the
right person that can help you
however the larger the company the more
difficult it will be to make this happen
this just requires your patience
and again being polite and not expecting
the company to do what you are asking
many times this is just a formality and
sometimes companies will act on it so be
sure to approach this with the right
expectations
the next thing I want to look at are
business listings
these are the easy ways to establish
links and ensure that links are where
they should be and also opportunities
look for business directories especially
if your company has a local presence
you can utilize Chamber of Commerce
lists Association lists or local
listings
if they are on websites see if they
offer links that can go to your website
rather than just the list of businesses
that are in the area
even on a larger level you can look for
associations directories or listings
where you can add your business or
double check if your business is there
and always ensure that your business
name address phone number and URL are
correct complete and consistent with
other listings
the next level will require some active
marketing and that's where you search
for opportunities
you can go out and look for other
resource lists within your industry or
directories of businesses within your
industry and you can get a link many
times through membership or submitting
your business as a resource
however you may want to step up your
marketing
you can do that by interviewing your
clients seeing if they might be willing
to provide a testimonial and a link to
your website
you may also want to go out and find
other communities online maybe some
social communities that are relevant to
your industry
get involved with those communities fill
out a profile and get involved by
contributing information
by sharing information you'll find that
people like getting information and
they'll respond by linking to your site
another option is to utilize the tool
that you had for indexing your links
from the first step you can also add
your competitors and you can look at
their backlinks you can look and see
which websites and which domains are
linking to your competitors but you
always need to go and see why what are
those other sites linking to
and what is the nature of that link
sometimes it may exclude you from being
able to approach competitors backlinks
and ask them for links
however if they're being linked to by
companies that are simply stating here
are vendors in this space and they are
linking your competitors and you're not
there
then it might make a lot of sense for
you to approach and ask if you can be
listed as well
however be sure that the links to your
competitors are not from a consumer or
customer relationship
in that case it might be out of line for
you to ask for a link
make sure if you approach anyone who's
linking to a competitor and asking for a
link to your site
make sure the context is right and that
it makes sense for them
and that's the ultimate judge of value
does it benefit somebody else to link to
your site
we all know that it will benefit you but
when you present your link request you
need to offer value and the benefit for
others to link to you
so be sure that you present it in a way
that is beneficial
and good for those people that will be
adding the link they're the ones that
have to take the work to do it and
they're also the ones that are adding a
recommendation for you and your business
so as always you need to be considerate
and patient
now the best way to build links is by
creating something that people like and
sharing it
you see the best way to build links is
by creating value through content or
information or entertainment
you see when people like things they
link to it
if they find a study or a white paper or
research that you performed
they link to it
if you post a infographic that explains
something
and it's attractive people link to it
you see that's what's most amazing about
linking I find that when we put most of
our effort into creating content that
people like
that's what builds the most valuable and
the most relevant links
and so what type of content well you can
create infographics videos top 10 lists
or articles articles with advice or
analysis of Market data or even research
that type of content people love it and
so when you publish it out you utilize
social media to extend the reach and the
visibility of that type of content
and when someone likes it they'll link
to it and recommend it to others
now people also like depending upon your
industry or your business they also like
some personality maybe some humor
people always like expert information
they like the cute this is why pictures
of cats tend to be liked and linked to
more than almost anything else
and also the unexpected
if you can inject any of that into your
content that just makes it more valuable
more personable and again more shareable
by other people and every time someone
shares it it builds a link to your site
you see the best linking is when people
like something
when you create something that people
like and share you might be surprised at
the many opportunities there are
to get links based on your content
I've seen many many blogs based on
cooking fashion Arts Sports music
and when people specialize within a
specific topic they always find an
audience and so anything they publish
builds links
even on certain social media sites such
as Pinterest
people upload pictures on articles and
infographics especially about
landscaping flowers food cars you name
it there is a special interest for
anything and you can develop links from
those social sites to your site
and it can generate traffic
even with a Blog developing articles
that talk about upcoming events new
music Sports whatever it is when you
create content that people like
it takes the longest amount of time to
build content for building links when
you develop your own content that's the
biggest investment you'll make in time
and research and writing and
presentation
however
the result is that when you develop that
content
you will receive the best and highest
quality links and the most valuable
links are going to be to that content
as I mentioned before one high quality
link can be worth more than hundreds or
thousands of low quality links so my
best advice is to create content that
people like that they link to
and that will be high value links that
you'll generate to your site Google tag
manager thanks for joining and let's get
started with this simply learn webinar
so let's start out with why GTM so let's
just say you're Sam and you have your
own e-commerce website you want to
understand how people are interacting
with your website well Sam today's world
of websites contain a lot of
interactivity everything from videos to
PDF downloads to commenting to form
submissions uh to all sorts of chat
functionality interactivity going on
throughout the website so there's just a
lot that you need to track outside of
just page views and so really what GTM
does is they help you track all these
things I just mentioned everything from
somebody clicking on the play button of
a PDF to somebody clicking on the submit
button a form to somebody entering in
something on a chat function so that's
what GTM is so why GTM because it helps
us track all that interactivity so all
GTM is is really allows you to really
place a piece of java code which is just
script and the script that's added to a
web page to collect information so
that's really what a tag is it's just
some script that gets put on a web page
in order for you to collect information
like page views clicks Etc and they send
it to third-party tools okay so that's
what GTM does it basically allows you to
take all these tags that collect
information and you can use them in GTM
so if you want to for example collect
how many people you know enter
a chat functionality and start chatting
well you're going to take that script
and you're going to put it in GTM and
GTM will then allow you to start
tracking that information so that's
really what GTM is it just allows you to
put tags into a container or think of it
as a toy box you have all these toys and
you want to track well you can put all
those those toys or tags in a toy box or
container and we're going to talk a
little bit more about that but before we
get into GTM let's just say you know
you're communicating with your developer
and there's a new user request on your
web page and you want to update the tag
well your developer considering it's
probably a small update your website is
probably gonna not
um hesitate and is going to go ahead and
turn around and do it normally and so
normally what happens is the developer
is going to go to the website and update
the tag well what if you have a few
things that you want to track all those
things I mentioned before from downloads
to clicks to you know somebody checking
out to watching a video well you're your
Web Master your web developer is going
to go well hold on a second now all
these requests are going to take time I
need to put them into the work queue so
to speak well what happens is when they
go into work queue usually it's going to
take some time and in some cases you as
a marketer need to launch a campaign and
you want to get that tracking added to
the website in time for the campaign
launch so you want to go ahead and
quickly turn around the tracking for
that particular campaign let's just say
you're launching a campaign and you're
sending people to a landing page that
has a form submission and you want to be
able to track how many people click on
the submit button of that form
submission well if you need to turn that
around your developer's like well I need
to put that in a work queue the time it
isn't going to always work out between
you and your developer is my point and
so that's where GTM comes in because
there is a solution update your tags
faster and that's Google tag manager so
when we say GTM that's what GTM stands
for a Google tag manager it's a place
for you to add tags quickly and easily
so tags remember are just Snippets of
code that allow you to track things on
your website interactively interactive
actively and basically when you have GTM
you can bypass the webmaster and do it
quickly and easily so that's what GTM is
all about so why GTM because we just
identified two benefits one you could
track all the interactivity on your
website and two you can bypass your web
developer or webmaster and so that's the
benefit of GTM so the benefit you get
those tags updated very quickly via
Google tag manager okay so that's what
tag manager is so what we're going to
talk about today is specifically what
tag manager is and what it does we're
going to list some of the benefits of
tag manager we're going to show you how
it works and then we're going to show
you how to get started with tag manager
tag manager if you're not familiar with
working with webmasters and dealing with
JavaScript and tags and all this jargon
is just new to you today okay well don't
fret sit back we're gonna take it slow
this is an introduction into Google tag
manager again let's start out with what
is tag manager so we've already
introduced it to some degree because we
already introduced it as a tool where
you can put all your tags into a toolbox
toy box or container so to speak right
and we already already mentioned that
hey you can bypass your webmaster so
you're probably thinking well if I'm if
you're not familiar with tag manager how
can I bypass my webmaster well first of
all it's a free tool and it's a Google
tool hence the name Google tag manager
and it helps you really that's the main
point it's deploy and track tags on your
website bypassing your webmaster so
that's tag manager and so examples of
tags that can be deployed via Google tag
manager are numerous these are just some
examples like Google analytics
Facebook's pixel tracking or Google ads
There's No Limit into the number of
texts you can track and tag manager
there is no limit you can add any number
of tracking tags and tag manager okay so
some of the benefits well again I we
just listed two you can put any tag into
tag manager and track that onto your
website and we know you can bypass your
web developer or webmaster and what it
also does is it also allows you to test
and deploy your JavaScript codes quicker
so remember these JavaScript codes or
Snippets of codes are just there to
track certain things on your website
whether that be a page view or somebody
clicking on a play button or tracking
somebody who converts or even just goes
to your website so the biggest benefit
is you can take that snippet of code
let's just say Facebook let's just say
you're doing Facebook marketing and you
want to put that Facebook pixel on your
website so that you could track people
who come from Facebook and convert well
you don't need to put that Facebook
pixel on your website you can go right
to tag manager and you can put that
snippet of code right in tag manager
really quickly and the other benefit
here is all tags are managed in one
place and that's that to me is really a
good benefit because when you start
adding tags on your website and you have
some tags and tag manager it just gets
very confusing so ideally all the
tracking codes you have on your website
needs to be in tag manager think about
that all the tracking so if you're doing
Bing or you're doing Facebook or you're
doing Twitter or you're doing LinkedIn
and you're doing Google you're doing all
this type of marketing on all these
different platforms you're going to have
tracking code for all these different
platforms and instead of putting all
that code on your website return gonna
slow down the slope load time of your
web page and website you want to put
them all in tag manager so they can be
organized and you you know exactly what
you're trying to track and the other
great benefit of tag manager is there's
a versioning control so let's just say
you have added tags to your website via
GTM for the last six months well and
let's just say you add another tag
yesterday if you added that tag
yesterday and something doesn't work
well you can just roll back to a
previous version It's that simple so you
have versioning and that's that's a good
thing when you have versioning you can
control what gets published and if
something doesn't work after it gets
published then you can roll back to a
previous version so it's a a peace of
mind so to speak just because you've had
code to your site there's no guarantee
it's going to work and so you can always
control what version you're dealing with
in tag manager and we'll talk a little
bit more about that so the biggest
benefit here to me with tag manager is
you have event tracking and so we talked
about some of the things you could track
on your website from videos from play
buttons to somebody clicking on the stop
on the video or causing it all the way
to somebody again chatting or let's just
say somebody clicking on that purchase
button on your website okay and you want
to track all these different things
these different interactivities and
buttons well event tracking is what
you're going to use to track all those
buttons and to me this is the biggest
benefit of tag manager and I'll show you
some examples as we go along and if we
didn't mention it already I'll mention
it again it is free tag manager is free
there's no limit so once you have tag
manager going you can add as many
tracking codes as you want there's no
limit on the number of tracking codes
you can add to tag manager okay so it's
free and you can use it to its fullest
Advantage okay so it's also high
security meaning that it has different
levels of permissions okay so you can
have uh somebody just go in and look at
the different tags and tracking codes
you have in GTM or you can ask somebody
who is very familiar with tag manager it
can go go in and add the tracking code
to tag manager and then publish that
tracking code when it gets added so
those are all the benefits let's talk
about how it works now specifically how
does tag Manager work because you're
like Rob okay again a lot of jargon you
know you you got tags and JavaScript and
and versioning and Publishing and all
this other stuff well I know I'm
throwing a lot at you at once but just
bear with me here okay so let's start
talking about how it actually works so
you have a website okay whatever that
domain is you have a website and there's
chances are on your website you have
some form of interactivity whether that
be a video whether that be a Blog
whether it be a form submission you have
a website with some interactivity and
let's just say you're even thinking
about getting ready to launch some type
of campaign on maybe Google or Facebook
and you want to drive traffic to your
website fair enough you're joining the
millions of other websites that are out
there that have interactivity that also
Drive track traffic to the website so in
comes Google tag manager and so tag
manager is important because again we
know we want to track people coming from
that Facebook campaign or that Google
campaign and interacting with our site
so if you are running Facebook and you
are running Google analytics well guess
what you want to put that tracking code
in tag manager so Google analytics being
a Google product works very nicely with
tag manager Facebook has its own
tracking code but you still want to be
able to track people who come from the
Facebook campaign to your website so
you're gonna get that tracking code from
Facebook and put it in tag manager
that's generally how it works so here
information from your website is shared
with another data source through tag
manager so think about that if I add
Facebook tracking code to tag manager or
let's just say a Google analytics
tracking code to tag manager tag manager
is the one that's pushing out and doing
all the heavy lifting they're the ones
that are going to controlling what code
gets fired and what code doesn't so if
you're putting the code in tag manager
tag managers controlling the code think
about it that way and let's show you an
example of what that looks like so here
I am I'm in tag manager I just went to
tag
manager.google.com and here I can see a
list of tags so in our conversation
we're talking about tracking Facebook
and we're talking about tracking Google
analytics well Google analytics is easy
because it's a Google product so here if
I look at all the different tracking
code I have on my website through tag
manager let's just take a look at Google
analytics so if you're going to use Tag
manager you might as well put the Google
analytics code in here so here I can see
I have Google analytics as a tag in tag
manager now for Facebook if I'm running
a Facebook campaign well I can take that
pixel tracking and put it in GTM as well
and here I can see Facebook pixel that
is that code is added to GTM I just
basically took what Facebook gave me and
put it in the Google tag manager so you
can see I can add Facebook and Google
analytics and again I can't stress it
enough any tracking code from any
platform I can add to Google tag manager
in order to track the behavior from
those sources so let's take a little bit
deeper dive into how tag manager works
so I just showed you an example of how
you could take Facebook and Google
analytics code and put it into tag
manager but if you're not familiar with
tag manager then how do I do that well
let's talk about the structure and how
tag manager works so when you have a tag
manager account you have a container
remember I mentioned Toy Box earlier you
have a bunch of toys if they're they're
code and you're tracking different bits
of code from different platforms like
Facebook think of those as toys and you
have a toy box okay well that's what
this code is and that's what a container
is the code is the code and that's going
to go into the toy box or container and
so the way tag manager works is you have
tags triggers and variables so if I take
my Facebook tracking code and put it
into a container I need to set up a tag
and a trigger okay so let's take a look
at what that is so first if I go back to
tag manager I'm going to have an account
and if I have an account I'm going to
have a container so here I'm just going
to click on an account with a container
and a container is nothing more than
what website you're adding the tracking
code to okay that's all the container is
we're just letting tag manager know this
is the website we're adding all this
code to so you have tags triggers and
variables that's the structure of tag
manager so tags are just what it says
tags what are we trying to quote unquote
tag well if it's Google analytics that's
easy here I could see I have Google
analytics added so if I click on Google
Google analytics here's my tag and if I
take a little bit of a deeper dive there
since Google analytics is a Google
product it integrates already with tag
managers it's pretty easy I can just
choose Google analytics then I'm going
to check page view and that's my tag now
every tag needs a trigger okay so I need
to tell tag manager how or when to fire
the Google analytics tracking code so in
this case I'm going to tell tag manager
to fire on all pages so if I get
somebody a visitor to my website
analytics is firing on all pages so
whatever page that visitor lands on
Google analytics is gonna fire so that's
really what it comes down to is I have a
tag and I need to tell tag manager when
to trigger that tag that's really what
the structure of tag manager is it's
tags triggers and variables and
variables what we're going to talk about
here in a couple minutes but do you have
a piece of code you're going to go ahead
and put that into tag manager you're
going to tag it and then you're going to
fire that trigger so let's take a look
at another example here if I go back
here you can see Facebook well here's my
Facebook pixel okay that's my tag so
when is it gonna fire well it's gonna
fire on a specific domain or subdomain
that's basically what we're doing we're
trying to tell GTM when to fire that
particular tag so those are the three
main components a tag okay which is
going to contain the JavaScript code
that you get from say Facebook the
trigger so you're going to go into tag
manager and tell tag manager when to
fire that code that's the trigger and
then you have variables and so variables
are basically just additional
information that tag manager may need
for your tag and Trigger to work so
that's what a variable is it's there
here to get the tag and Trigger to fire
so variables are divided into built-in
and user-defined variables so common
used variables include say page path or
page URL or hostname or click class
again they're there and these examples I
just gave you are there to get your tag
and Trigger to work think about it that
way they're just that's a component and
if I go into tag manager here and here
on the left side I can see variables so
remember I have built-in and user
defined so built in means that tag
manager already built these for me so in
case I need to get my trigger to work
with my tag I can use a variable so
those are built in and then I have user
defined so these are what I Define these
are what I created and again the
variables are there to get the tag and
Trigger to work okay so that's the job
of the variable the job of the tag is to
host that JavaScript code okay in the
case of Facebook or analytics that's
where we're putting our code so here if
I click on AdWords remarketing again
it's a Google product so I don't really
need to even deal with code I'm just
going to select Google AdWords for
marketing okay so you can see GTM
integrates nicely with some of the other
Google products but let's just say you
have a Facebook pixel tracking code
you're going to choose custom and you're
going to put the code here so that's
part of the tag and then the trigger
again is there to get the tag to fire so
you're telling GTM when to fire the tag
and the variable is there to help you
make sure that that trigger and that tag
work together so that's how all three
kind of work together you need the tag
to put the code you need the trigger to
tell GTM when to fire the tag in code
and the variables there to help you
define when that tag and Trigger should
work or how it should work so again
review tab bags are they're just small
codes of JavaScript or tracking pixels
on your website and so tags are allowed
to manage events like scroll track and
remarketing clicks downloads files play
buttons you name it it even clicks on
external links for example let's just
say you have a click uh or a Facebook uh
icon on your site and when somebody
clicks on it they go to Facebook you
want to maybe track that you're going to
create a tag okay the trigger is there
because you need to tell GTM when to
fire that tag so it's a certain
condition whether it's you know fire the
tag if the URL equals facebook.com or
some other condition so the tag cannot
be created until the creation of the
corresponding trigger so tags and
triggers go together you can't just
create a tag and not have a trigger
otherwise your tag will never fire and
then the variable is there again it
stores the information when defining a
trigger or transferring data to tag so a
variable has a variety variety of data
okay so you pick and choose the variable
you want to use with that trigger okay
so you're making sure that by defining a
variable you're making sure that you're
telling GTM how that trigger should be
fired so let's take a look at another
example here of how all three play
together if I'm in this account I'm in
this container if I look down here I can
see Google optimize that's another
Google product so what I'm doing here is
I just chose Google optimize as my tag
it's already integrated so what does
that mean I don't even need to deal with
any code I'm just going to select
optimize well we have the tag Google
optimize but we need to tell GTM how to
fire that and so here we're going to
tell GTM to fire it on all pages so
that's basically a very simple example
because we're firing it on all pages so
if I want to look at something specific
again Facebook here's is my tag here's
my code what's my trigger well my
trigger is it's gonna fire on specific
Pages how do I know that well if I look
at the trigger here I can see the
trigger is a page view but I'm telling
it to fire on this particular hostname
so the tag and Trigger go hand in hand
[Music]
so how to get started with tag manager
so first things first you have to create
that account so you're going to go to
tagmanager.google.com or you can do a
search for Google tag manager and you're
going to create your account and then
when you create your account what's
going to happen is you're going to set
up a container and when you set up a
container you have choices so you could
set it up for your website for an app on
iOS or maybe Android or you can even set
it up for amp Etc an accelerated mobile
page so most people by default are
probably going to set up tag manager for
their website and so when you do that
when you actually select website what's
gonna happen is you're going to get some
Google tag manager code in return and so
the whole idea here is you're going to
do a swap what you're doing doing is
basically saying Okay Google I'm gonna
take this Google tag manager code and
I'm going to put it on my website I'm
gonna put it on every page in my website
so notice tag manager has two scripts
one goes in the head as high as possible
the other goes into the body tag as high
as possible and so what you're doing is
you're making a deal you're putting this
tag manager code on your website and in
return every code you deal with whether
that be Facebook or analytics or
optimize or remarketing or whatever it
is is gonna go in GTM okay it's gonna go
into the Container you created so you
need the tag manager code on your
website in order for tag manager to work
okay so when you add this code to your
website then you're free to start adding
all sorts of tags to your container but
if you don't have this tracking code on
your website then none of the tags you
add to your container are gonna work so
that's the idea yeah behind the
container and then one thing I wanted to
mention on the account is it's a Google
account so when you create your account
then make sure it's the same account you
use with say Google analytics or some
other Google product that's a good best
practice is always use the same email
address when you set up your account so
that it integrates nicely across all the
different platforms meaning you can go
from say Google analytics right to
Google tag manager in one browser
without having to log out or log in okay
so when you create the account you're
going to create your container if you
choose web then you're going to be asked
to place code on your website and when
you place that code on your website then
you are free to start using tag manager
and that means you're free to start
adding tags so if you want to know more
information about installing Google tag
manager then what I would recommend is
visit the quick start guide website of
GTM so again if you're curious as to
where that code is located in Google tag
manager well when you create an account
and you create a container that
container is going to have a specific ID
so if I click on that specific ID here's
where I can get my code okay so again
when I'm logged in to tag manager I'm
going to click on workspace but in the
top navigation I'm going to see my
unique GTM ID if I click on that that's
where my code is going to be located and
so again your code needs to go in the
header and there's another script that
needs to go in the body and if you're
not sure how to add the code to your
website well you can always click on the
quick start guide here okay and that'll
take you to a quick start guide page a
reference page related to Google tag
manager so let's talk about creating a
tag so once you get tag manager
installed I'm sure you're excited to get
going and create that first tag so let's
talk about how to create a tag and tag
manager so when you're in tag manager
all you need to do is basically you're
looking at all your tags if you click on
tag in the left side navigation you'll
see all your tags and there's a new
button there so you just click new and
so basically what you're going to do is
you're going to create your first tag
and so what I would recommend once you
get tag manager installed on your
website I would recommend setting the
first tag up as Google analytics so that
will get you going with tracking page
views on your website when some when
somebody visits your website okay so
ideally that's what you want to do you
want to get Google analytics as your
first tag and tag manager so what I'm
going to do is because analytics is a
Google product it's already integrated
nicely with tag manager so I'm just
going to click on Google analytics it's
going to be a page view that's what I'm
tracking and now I have to set up a
variable and so what it's going to do
it's going to ask me to set a select a
variable and so what you're going to do
is you're going to select new variable
and what you're going to do is you're
actually going to go and add your
tracking ID here that's going to be your
variable so where do I get my tracking
ID and analytics well if I'm in
analytics I'm going to go to admin and
then under property settings I'm going
to see my tracking ID and all you need
to do then is go to tag manager and
paste copy first you got to copy over
that tracking ID then you're going to go
to tag manager I'm going to paste it and
then that's going to create a variable
for you and then when you create that
variable you're going to see it in the
drop down here so I've already created
it and basically that's your tag with a
variable then what are you going to do
you're going to set up a trigger so see
I have some triggers already set up
you're going to see a default trigger
already set up for you and it's going to
be all pages so ideally what you want to
do is you you want to select all pages
in order for analytics to fire on all
pages so that's what we're doing we're
setting up a trigger we're basically
telling tag manager hey if I get a
visitor to any page on my website then I
want you to fire Google analytics so
that's basically in summary how to set
up your first tag and my recommendation
is your first tag should be Google
analytics and when you set up analytics
you're going to have to set up a
variable for the tracking ID and so you
get the tracking ID again from admin
property settings copy and paste that
tracking ID over save it you have your
variable that variable is going to be
included in with the tag then your
trigger is going to be all pages and
there you go you have your first tag you
have your first variable you have your
first trigger so that's basically what
you want to do and once you've added
that tag once you've added that trigger
then the only thing you need to do now
is basically publish the tag and so
anytime you save a tag you're going to
go ahead and submit it so that way it
gets published so again what you're
going to do is let's take a step back
here you're going to choose new tag
you're going to choose analytics from
the drop down menu you're going to
choose page view then basically you're
going to add your tracking ID so you can
set up the variable and then basically
that's what you need to do okay you're
going to add that tracking ID and then
voila that's your tag with a variable
and then once you've done that then
you're going to click submit so when you
click submit you're basically saying Hey
I want this tag to go live now this tag
and Trigger and once you've done that
then analytics is ready to go and
anytime somebody goes to your website on
any page tag manager is going to fire
Google analytics so the great thing here
is you have something called Google tag
assistant and that's a an extension that
works with chrome and so when you've
actually add a tag manager to your site
or you have analytics running in tag
manager you can confirm if those tags
are firing properly so let's take a look
at how Google tag assistant works okay
so if you just do a search for Google
tag assistant you're going to see here
that it's basically just an extension
that works in Chrome and unfortunately
it only works in Chrome browser it
doesn't work in any other browser so go
ahead and install that extension into
Chrome and when you do that you're going
to see this nice icon here in your
browser and now if you go to any website
and I click on Google tag assistant and
I click on enable Okay so basically I'm
loading Google tag assistant and now
once I refresh the page I can see that
this particular site has Google tag
manager installed and not only does it
have tag manager installed I can see
that it's also has Google analytics run
running I have also Google optimize
running and I have Google ads
remarketing tag running and tag manager
so that's what tag assistant does it
allows you to see if one tag manager is
on the site and if it is great what
other tags are firing on this particular
site so tag assistance telling me I have
these particular tags firing on that
site and they're firing within tag
manager so tag assistant is a great way
to confirm if one tag manager is on the
site and two what other tags are firing
on the site now another way you could
confirm if tag manager is firing on the
site is you can go into preview mode so
even before you submit and publish your
tag and Trigger you can click on the
preview mode so if I click preview in
tag manager so basically that's going to
put me in preview mode and so what does
that mean well that means that now I'm
free to go to my website and see if
those tags are firing and so let's take
a look at what that looks like so if I
go to the website and just click refresh
then what's going to happen is tag
manager is going to load in preview mode
just as you see here okay so that's
going to take a second couple seconds to
load up and now what can I see in
preview mode I could see that I have GTM
firing but I also have some other tags
found on this page remarketing I have
Google analytics I have Google optimize
I have some other tags firing as well
and so the preview mode shows me what
tags are firing on any given page and I
can also see what tags did not fire okay
so here I have a number of tags already
in GTM but they didn't fire on this
particular page so let's just say I
clicked on the Donate now button I'm
still in preview mode so I'm gonna be
able to see what tags fired now I could
see I have a couple attacks that have
fired on this particular page and then I
can see what tags did not fire on this
page okay so that's the preview mode you
can use the preview mode before you even
submit a tag and Trigger to see if it
fires and that's the great benefit of
tag manager so if you're not sure if
something's going to fire or not then
you can always go into preview mode um
and if you are sure it's gonna fire then
you can go ahead and submit it so you
can leave preview mode and just go ahead
and submit that particular tag and
Trigger so here I'm going to leave
preview mode and now once I'm done and
I'm sure the tag is going to fire and go
ahead and submit all my changes that
I've worked on in terms of setting up
tags and triggers so that's really GTM
in a nutshell so I have my tags okay my
tags are just Snippets of code that I'm
going to put in whether that be Facebook
or vet tracking or any other Google
product like optimize or page view then
I have my triggers my triggers are there
to tell GTM when to fire that tag and
the variables are there to help those
tags and triggers work together so
remember that particular variable we set
up for Google analytics okay so here it
is right here because we want to tell
GTM what property to specifically fire
in Google analytics so that's why we set
up that variable but there are all sorts
of variables Google tag manager has
built in or variables already created
for you or you can specifically Define a
variable so variables are there to help
the tags and triggers work together so
when you set up a tag you set up a
trigger you use a variable you can
always go into preview mode preview it
by going to the website seeing if it
fires if it fires then voila you can go
ahead and click submit and that will
publish the tag and Trigger and you're
good to go that's pretty much how tag
manager works and again I can't stress
that there is an unlimited number of
tags you can add to tag manager there's
no limit so you got everything from
anything from Google to non-google to
event tracking okay to Facebook to
anything that you want to track you want
to be able to put into tag manager and
again there's versioning that's one of
the great benefits of tag manager so if
I want to go back to an older version I
can simply do that so here you can see
I'm on version 32. that's how tag
manager works and I can't stress that
you know tag manager is there to help
you track interactivity on the site
because if you have a site that's
interactive that has a video that has a
download button let's just say you know
you have all sorts of newsletter
sign-ons Facebook YouTube buttons on
your website just like this website does
and you won't be able to track how many
people click on that particular button
well you're going to need tag manager
and when you have tag manager you're
going to be able to track all of these
button clicks and interactivity on your
website choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1 000 Plus
hours of video content for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
we're going to talk about how to rank
number one on Google so let's get
started and um let's go with the
scenario that you have a friend named
Sam and he has a website where he sells
shoes but Sam doesn't understand
why his website's not ranking number one
on Google and so typically ranked number
one on Google there are some factors
involved and those are factors that are
going to help Sam get his website ranked
number one on Google so he can sell his
shoes get traffic and convert that
traffic to conversions so there are
factors involved and so what are those
factors well it always starts with
keyword research so in order to rank for
a website where you sell shoes or you
sell products other products like
clothing or food or you're an automobile
website you know you're a mechanic it
doesn't matter whether you're selling to
customers or selling to other businesses
you have to start with the keyword
research and so we're going to go into
really explicit detail on how to conduct
a proper keyword research and then the
second factor involved is high quality
content so in order to rank high on
Google search you need to have high
quality content so we're going to go
over what's involved with creating high
quality content then we're going to take
that content we're going to optimize it
using on-page elements and website level
factors so we're going to take into
account what's involved with with your
website and what's involved with
specific pages on your website in order
to rank number one on Google then we're
going to get into the off-site
engagement so when it comes to ranking
on Google you need to optimize your
website and you need to do some elements
off your website you need to be engaging
off your website meaning on other
websites and so we're going to talk
about what's involved with off-site
engagement so SEO being a major channel
for most companies and websites where
the opportunity to drive a lot of
traffic is there but you have to earn
that reward the reward is a lot of
traffic but you have to earn the reward
there's a lot of work involved and so
ideally what we want to do is follow
what we call the 80 20 rule when it
comes to search engine optimization and
ranking on Google and what do we mean by
the 80 20 rule well 80 20 means we're
investing 20 of our effort and 80
percent of the results are obtained so
we want to invest 20 and get back 80.
that's basically what we mean by 80 20.
so for example if 20 of our targeted
keywords bring in 80 of the traffic then
that's following the 80 20 rule or 20
percent of our landing pages Drive 80
percent of the overall traffic that's
following the 80 20 rule or 20 percent
of our backlinks past 80 percent of our
link juice that's the 80 20 rule meaning
these targeted keywords these targeted
landing pages these trying to Target
backlinks using off-site engagement we
want to put in 20 of our effort on those
keywords landing pages and backlinks in
return for 80 percent of the results so
without further Ado let's get started
with the keyword research let's talk
about that keyword research for a
website with shoes and it doesn't really
matter what particular product you have
if you need to rank number one on Google
it all starts with the keywords as I
mentioned before and so in this example
if you have a website where you sell
shoes for kids you're going to want to
be found for certain keywords so the
obvious keyword here would be shoes for
kids well every key word that you target
has search volume associated with it so
that means when we talk about search
volume we're talking about how many
people on average type in that keyword
or related keyword on google.com or
Google search and there's always an
average number of searches associated
with every keyword and we call that
search volume how much search volume so
obviously if we're going to Target a
keyword we want to have as much volume
as possible however there's always going
to be competition for those keywords
meaning there's always going to be other
websites who want to rank number one on
Google for the same keywords and we call
that competition or difficult reality so
for every keyword you're going to have
volume and you're going to have
competition or difficulty and the
difficulty ranges as well depending on
the tool you use and we'll get into that
in a minute but search volume is how
much on average people are typing in
that keyword or close variance of that
keyword and the difficulty is measured
in terms of how many other websites are
trying to rank for the same keyword and
so ideally when it comes to keyword
research we want to find that nice
balance we want high volume and we want
low competition but at the same time we
want to focus on keywords that are
highly relevant to our business so if
we're selling shoes for kids and shoes
for kids is highly relevant has high
volume and low competition then that's a
keyword we want to Target so we always
want to focus in on those three areas so
there's always a trade-off with keywords
so shoes for kids kids might have high
volume but also might have high
competition or difficulty if we look for
another keyword that's just as relevant
for example shoes for children it may
still have high search volume but the
competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
may be a better keyword for us to Target
instead of something highly competitive
like shoes for kids we can focus on
another relevant keyword like shoes for
children with just as much volume and
lower competition and the reason why we
want lower competition is because we
want to be able to rank for that keyword
so the higher the competition the harder
it is for us to rank number one on
Google for that keyword and so the whole
idea Beyond keyword research is
analyzing and choosing the best keywords
so we want to identify a list of
keywords that are always relevant we
want to choose the keyword that your
competitors are ranking for and we want
to use third party great tools to choose
keywords to identify which keywords have
low competition and what keywords have
high search volume so one thing to take
into consideration when you're doing
keyword research is that the longer the
key word phrase or in other words long
tail keywords or keywords with three
keywords in the phrase or more you're
going to always have less competition
but there's always a trade-off with long
tail keywords meaning the longer the
keyword phrase there's going to be less
volume but the trade-off is less
competition and so what we want to do is
we want to brainstorm some ideas and
find those relevant keywords so let's
look at an example here so if we go to
Google ads so Google ads has a toe call
Keyword Planner and let's just say I
have a a website where I'm selling dried
figs and if I'm selling dried figs I
want people to buy these dried figs
however in order to track them I want to
be able to show them that hey we have a
bunch of recipes and if I show you a
bunch of recipes where you can use dried
figs maybe you'll buy these dried figs
to use in these recipes and so we're
going to look for keywords related to
bread recipes because if we can optimize
for our recipes page for bread then that
will attract an audience who wants to
make bread and use dried figs with those
bread recipes so that's the example I'm
going to give here and so if I look at
the Keyword Planner and Google ads if I
just type in bread recipes what Google
is going to do is they're going to give
me an average monthly search volume so I
can see the average monthly search
volume here is 60 500. and so in order
to do keyword research what I would
recommend is keep a spreadsheet and so
the idea behind the spreadsheet is to
document the volume and the competition
you're getting for certain words so if I
go into a spreadsheet here my theme of
keywords is bread recipes my keyword is
bread recipes and my volume therefore is
going to be sixty thousand five hundred
however if I go back into Google's
Keyword Planner Google's telling me that
competition is low so that's great I
want high volume I want low competition
but how low is low so we want to be
careful so if we're going to put in
numbers into a spreadsheet we want to
figure out what that competition really
is for the keyword bread recipes so if I
go to Google and just type in bread
recipes I'm going to be able to see
771 billion results for the keyword
bread recipes now is 771 billion our
real competition maybe maybe not what we
want to do is put in a syntax and we
want to put in the syntax all in title
and then colon space and then our
keyword and the reason why we do that in
search is because we want to be able to
identify the true competitive number or
the true number of websites or trying to
rank for bread recipes and if we put in
the syntax all entitled colon and then
our keyword bread recipes we'll be able
to see that there are 998
000 results that's a lot lower than 771
billion so that means that 998
000 sites or listings have the keyword
bread recipes in the title tag and the
title tag is what shows up in the search
engine results and so if I look down and
scroll down here I can see bread recipes
or every one of these title tags so
title tag is an important element to
rank number one on Google and we'll talk
about that in a few minutes but if we
understand that there are 998 000
results with bread recipe fees in the
title tag then this tells us that those
are the websites who are trying to rank
number one on Google for that keyword
and therefore those are the websites we
need to jump over in order for our
website to rank number one on Google and
so therefore I'm going to put in 998
000 in my spreadsheet as the competitive
number and so now I could see for the
keyword bread recipes I have 60 500 and
if my competition is 998 000 then my Kei
or keyword Effectiveness index or in
other words the ratio of volume to
competition is six percent so that's
nothing more than volume divided by
competition so that tells me that my Kei
or my ratio between volume competition
is six percent so remember we want more
volume than we want competition so
anytime you do a keyword research you're
going to find a number a different
relevant keywords so if I go back into
Google's Keyword Planner if I typed in
bread recipes you could see that Google
is going to give me a number of
different keywords related to bread
recipes let's just say I have another
keyword that I want to think about
optimizing for being ranked on Google
for and that's banana bread recipe very
similar keyword has bread recipes except
it's a little longer tail now if I type
in banana bread recipe and Google's
Keyword Planner now I can see the
average monthly search volume has
actually gone up it's 368
000. I can also see the competition is
low so those are good signs so now I can
see 368
000 I'm going to go ahead and put that
in my spreadsheet now I'm gonna go into
Google I'm gonna put in my syntax all in
title I'm going to put in banana bread
recipe I'm going to hit enter and now I
can see I have 233
1000 results with the keyword banana
bread recipe in the title tag so if I
look at the title tags I can see banana
bread recipe banana bread recipe banana
bread recipe on all the listings in the
Google search results so that tells me I
have 233
000 results that I have to jump over in
order to rank number one on Google so
I'm going to put 233
000 in my spreadsheet now I can see my
Kei or my volume to competition ratio is
157 158 and so to me that's a lot better
number to work with or in other words
that's a lot better keyword because it's
just as relevant and it has a higher
ratio of volume to competition so
therefore banana bread recipe is going
to be a better keyword to optimize for
in order to rank number one on Google so
that's the whole idea behind keyword
research you want to brainstorm ideas
there are plenty of tools out there so
the tool I recommend is Google ads
Keyword Planner Google is going to give
you how much search volume they're going
to tell you the competition but then
you're going to go into Google search
you're going to use the syntax on title
to get a more accurate read on the
actual competitive number and so to find
out how keywords that your competitors
are ranking for you can use those
keyword tools that I mentioned another
tool that I use is mass so Moz if you go
to moz.com they have a tool called
keyword Explorer so if we just type in
the keyword for example bread recipes
it's going to be able to tell us how
much volume and the difficulty so you
can use other tools at your disposal
figure out the volume and the difficulty
there are plenty of tools out there but
the one thing I would just make sure is
you use everything at your disposal so
you can use social media to find the
most shared article for a particular
topic or keyword like bread recipes you
could check other platforms that have a
lot of shared content like Reddit and
quora where you can ask people about
certain topics using keywords to figure
out how much competition or volume there
might be you could stay up to date on
industry news to get an idea of what
types of keywords are trending but when
it comes to keywords and keyword
research remember for every web page we
want to be able to pick two keywords we
want a primary and secondary keyword so
when we do keyword research and we enter
all our keywords into our spreadsheet we
want to be able to have a number of
different keywords in this case we're
focusing on the theme bread recipes we
want to have different keywords because
we want to be able to choose a primary
keyword and a secondary keyword because
says we want to be able to focus on
multiple keywords for each page because
we don't want to put necessarily all our
eggs in one basket meaning we won't want
to put all our emphasis just on one
keyword to rank for we want multiple
keywords to try and rank for so the
primary keyword can Define the nature of
our business the secondary keyword could
be just highly relevant to our keyword
at the end of the day we want to choose
multiple keywords to try and rank on
Google for that page so for example we
have a Blog and we're using ice cream
recipes and we're blogging about ice
cream recipes we can have a primary
keyword that is about ice cream recipes
or homemade ice cream recipes we're
going to always want to find out what
the volume and the competition is our
secondary keyword could be built around
other similar keywords like low-fat ice
cream recipes or fat free ice cream
recipes or low-fat homemade ice cream
recipes those are complementary keywords
just like our bread recipes and banana
bread recipe so one thing we want to do
when we do keyword research is we want
to be able to Target one keyword per
content when you can Target many we want
to be able to Target multiple keywords
not necessarily Target one keyword and
so we want to be able to Cluster
keywords so we don't want to Target just
one we want to Target multiple keywords
per page and when we talk about
clustering if we go back to our keyword
research what we're doing is we're
clustering a bunch of keywords under the
theme bread recipes and so by looking at
the volume looking at the competition
looking at the Kei we can choose
different keywords for our page and
that's what we mean by clustering we
want to Cluster keywords into a Content
frame so why Target only one keyword per
content when we can Target many because
we don't want to put all our eggs in one
basket we don't want to Target just one
key word we want to Target many and so
that means clustering your keywords into
a theme and choosing multiple keywords
for that particular page and when we do
that we have a better opportunity to
rank high on Google Search and the whole
idea behind ranking high on Google
Search is we can get the volume so if we
know we're ranked number one on Google
search for bread recipes or banana bread
recipe we know we stand a chance of
getting a majority of the volume
associated with that keyword and if we
can get the volume and get the traffic
then we can get the conversions so let's
move on to high quality content and talk
about the impact content has on your
ability to get your website ranked
number one on Google so let's just say
you have content on your website and the
content is ranking on you know page four
of Google and it's that blog with ice
cream recipes and if it's just content
for the sake of content is not really
informative then it's not necessarily
going to get good engagement in the eyes
of Google you know they want to rank
content that's very informative it's
very fresh it's exciting to read it's
interesting it's going to have good
engagement so if it's a recipe or an
article about any topic if it's the
content is just non-informative then
you're not going to get good engagement
and when you don't get good engagement
if people don't stay on the site to
engage in the content and they just
leave the website after landing on the
page causing a bounce then the content
is just going to continue to fall down
the rankings and we want to prevent that
we want to move up the rankings we want
to be number one on Google we don't
necessarily want to fall in the rankings
for our content so content is a key
driver and being able to rank number one
on Google so if the content is on page
nine what can we do well we want to be